e
good morning everyone welcome to the
Monday March 10th edition of the science
technology and energy committee we have
a morning of work sessions and an
afternoon of executive sessions so
before we get started I'll ask you all
to rise and join representative L relle
allegiance to the of the United States
of America and to the repblic for stand
na
all okay thanks to
everyone with a little bit of luck by
the time we can conclude today's
activities we will be done with our
house bills for
2025 and then we'll wait for Senate
bills
although we may retain a bill or two who
knows but um we will wait for Senate
bills which probably won't start heading
our way until about the 1st of April so
we'll have a little bit of a break over
the second half of March now we might
have time for some educational activity
during that period we'll see how it
goes so I want to begin this morning by
tackling some of the easy stuff first in
our work session and talk about
hp450 relative to commercial property
assessed clean energy and
resiliency also known as C
Pacer as you will
recall we passed Senate Bill four which
was the same bill with a couple of minor
edits earlier this year and that Bill
had already been passed by the Senate
when it came to us when we passed it
through the house it then went to the
governor's desk and it has been signed
into law therefore we
can without reservation itl House Bill
450 does anybody have any objection any
questions seems pretty straightforward
to me okay now let's talk about three
more
complicated
bills complicated in the sense that
there are three of them
um but not that complicated in the sense
of what the bills are trying to do which
is to do something about residential
condominum condominium
property use of electric rates electric
meters
so I'm going to ask representative
Bernardi who chaired a subcommittee work
on this
issue to give us an unofficial and
informal review of the subcommittee's
activities and tell
us if they accomplished anything that we
can use so representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair yes so the
subcommittee met and uh reviewed
essentially two options one was to have
a named individual in the condo
association take the uh uh point of
being the person on the the common bill
for uh well and Sewer um and that was uh
not well received uh in many aspects so
a a um second alternative which is to
take one of the three bills and I think
it's
539 537 okay uh so we're talking 537 539
and 680 take 537 and amend it to
basically say that uh condo uh
Association uh um can take that uh on
line and uh have it build by the
respective utilities at the residential
rate and the discussions from Unitil was
the only uh company here at the time um
was that the concern was make sure that
it is taking a dedicated line for just
well and sewer and naming it as a line
that would be uh transferred to uh
residential billing as opposed to
commercial or what they call General
billing um and that it is not there's no
requirement to divide it amongst all the
potential individuals served by the line
so that is I what I believe our
amendment makes clear at least when
Unitil looked at the the uh um language
they they agreed with that
um the concerns earlier raised by
eversource W was that uh there's still a
potential for cheating if someone wants
and I'm using that word more boldly than
they did um if if they uh if if someone
if a condo association wanted to claim
something that really wasn't a well in
sewer line uh as as well as it
potentially opens this Prospect up for
coming to us in the future with well I
want to add uh the uh the common washer
dryer area or whatever else to the list
of of lines so that's where we were um
I'm going to ask uh Tom Corman who
actually pursued the uh Amendment
language through OS to uh um give a
little more detail on it but that's
out representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr clerk
representative Bernardi for that that
press yeah so there there were really
two issues going on one being that these
meters these are shared meters for
residential unit
for well and septic that's all we're
talking about well and septic
residential units shared meters there
are two issues one being that they were
charged uh or being buildt at commercial
rates because the bill was going to the
homeowners association rather than to
individual residential units and HOAs
are considered commercial and then how
to actually build the individual units
because not all HOAs have that ability
in their bylaws so what this amendment
does is it makes clear that if there is
a shared meter that is serving only
residential well or septic than it is to
be build at residential rates only those
meters and that the HOA shall build the
individual units on each meter
equally there were two additions that we
put in after the sub committee meeting
and those are applying to uh a municipal
or County aggregation in the case that
they're direct billing right now I don't
know of any that are but in case they're
direct billing so the same rules would
apply to them and then also it was
pointed out that there were some
Municipal Electric utilities and uh Miss
Stone was kind enough to send me a list
of every town in the state and every
utility serving that town for every
every service water sewer and electric
um I grabbed that web page that she sent
me I wrote some python code to parse out
um which are the municipal Electric
utilities to verify that that the only
utilities that were not the the four
that we usually see are municipal ones
so there's a section on Municipal
Electric utilities again just saying if
they're billing they're billing at
residential
rates thank you would you go through the
amendment uh line by line essentially
and tell us what the changes that the
amendment makes to the Le to the
original introduced Bill sure now of
course there were three introduced bills
so um so what what we decided was to
just take one of them and just put
everything in that so that we don't have
to vote on three things things and have
three different things on consent so the
idea would be to itl the other two yes
yes definitely it itl the other two if
we approve uh F the changes to
537 so uh let's see in section one uh we
changed let me get the original here so
I can
compare we changed um what
paragraph oh gosh where is this original
we changed what paragraph We were
changing in section one I don't even
know if I have the original
here but anyway I know that we we
changed what paragraph We were changing
in section one uh and it seemed like uh
paragraph h of that particular uh
paragraph of the RSA was was the right
place to put it so uh we added and
whether any commercial or business
enterprises are permitted what we think
in is in the right
place um on section two we actually
moved that the original Bill had that I
think in RSA 378 which is about public
utilities but section two is about the
chargeback saying that the
HOA shall charge back the shared meter
costs to the individual units and it
didn't seem appropriate for that to be
in the RSA on public utilities it
belongs in the RSA on Condominiums so we
moved it to RSA 356b
which is about
Condominiums so there's uh a new
paragraph paragraph 2A paragraph 2 is is
the paragraph that says essentially if
the hoa's bylaws allow it they can
charge back various things and then here
uh 2A says regardless of the condominium
instruments the cost shall be uh charged
back so even if the bylaws don't
specifically permit it then it it can be
septics um section three is essentially
the same as in the original bill um we
may have made some minor wording changes
but essentially the
same section
four uh at least uh lines
through um through two on the next page
on page two are the same and then we
added uh this new section uh on on lines
3 to8 of page two um we added this
section saying that uh this applies also
to Rural Electric cooperatives I think
that was in the original bill but we may
have changed where this goes I forget
but we want to make sure that Rural
Electric cooperatives are covered
basically the New Hampshire Electric
Co-op and then sections five and six are
the same wording as before for but uh
for municipal and County aggregations
and for municipal Electric
utilities one other thing I want to
point out and I mentioned this in in the
email to the committee the amended
analysis on page three misses an
important point in in paragraph one
which is that this bill applies only for
res shared residential well and septic
we want to make sure everybody
understands that we're not talking about
shared lighting or heating a swimming
pool or anything like that it's really
septic representative Harrington yeah
obviously a lot of changes here I just
wanted to make sure I don't
sorry I'm not sure this is an issue or
not but I just wanted to make sure we're
being cons considered um the utilities
are regulated by the by the Pu whether
they're electric or water or sore
private utilities but Municipal
Utilities are exempt from their uh
approval so that doesn't create any
problem
here I don't think so I mean the whole
point here is just how at what rate are
you building a particular meter right
we're not saying that the rates change
we're just saying that this particular
meter you're not building it at a
General commercial rate you're building
it at a residential rate because it is
use is 100% for residential units so it
would be up to I don't know the city
council or whatever to when they're
reviewing let's say the Water Company's
uh proposed rate structure um for that
town the municipal they would be the
ones who would be the enforcing body to
make sure they comply with the law and
not the Pu yeah and again this this
isn't even about the water this is about
the electric meter and that's all it's
only about the electric meter serving a
a well pumped or a septic
system okay so it's not for water just
just for electricity it's for getting
water via electricity but it's it's not
for water service we still have some
inicial electric companies as well so
yeah that's right and and and and you
know that's why I wrote The Python code
to find that there were five okay thank
you representative Thomas oh Wendy
Thomas yes thank you Mr chair um in
describing the uh Amendment you said
that the HOA would build
equally God bless
you um does that mean they would they
would split the bill according to the
number of households that are on the
meter and my second question is are the
HOAs allowed to add a management fee to
this now that they have to split the
bills or is that beyond the scope of
this so uh to your first question yes so
if there were two houses or two units uh
being served by a meter they are build
equally uh we didn't really think about
a management fee I mean the HOA has
various billing that they do one other
point I I could have made and should
have made is that the way things are
currently regardless of whether these
Wells uh the these meters are built at
residential or commercial rates what's
happening is that the bill goes to the
HOA and the HOA distributes that cost
over all the units in the condo so
what's happening is people who are not
being served by these shared meters are
paying a part of those shared meters and
the whole point here is No it should be
paid only by the people who the meters
are
serving um my additional question follow
up are we in discussion or all right
follow up whatever um my additional
question is um how do you differentiate
between a unit that has two people in it
and a unit that has eight people in it
which is obviously going to be using
more more more energy more electricity
yeah we thought about that and there's
really just no way to tell right the the
meter it's one meter the meter is the
meter and and this is the only feasible
with so I was told that there may be
some concerns with this amendment
language so I would like to ask Miss
Stone from the Department of energy if
she has any
concerns about this amendment
consider good morning and welcome back
good morning thank you Mr chair uh for
the record Megan Stone with the
Department of energy um the department
does still have some concerns um with
this we do have some concerns um like
representative Thomas raised uh that if
there depending on whether there's two
units or or more units that uh might be
on one meter we also do still have some
concerns about um other lines that may
be running to the meter uh what it
whether it's a shared laundry facility
or um something like that that could be
more common use and whether the
utilities would have to to go inspect
all of these lines to make sure they are
just well in septic um or if there are
things running to that and then if you
have to change lines um and all the
implications that come with that and the
cost um so we do still have some
concerns with that um and we the
department still also has some concerns
with
um
how basically how would a change impact
cost recovery um and through rates and
then ultimately how would that flow to
all customers we do so there would be a
cost shift there and we do still have
that could you explain that cost shift a
little in a little more detail please
sure so um
with if you're changing the rate um
there could be a potential underc
collection of costs for the
utility by by changing the rate from
commercial to indust to residential
yes representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman right and and I understand the
point I I would argue that in fact
what's been happening is there's been a
cost shift where people who are are
using these meters for just residential
units are paying more than they should
have because they were getting charge
use representative
Harrington I I think the issue on cost
shifting is um has to be addressed
somewhat so the utility now collects x
amount of dollars because they're
building them as commercial and
Industrial if they make this change
they'll be built as residential and
they'll collect something less than x
amount it'll be x minus something and I
think with the bills intend of the bill
is to say well that's what they should
be collecting but the utilities is not
going to say oh well we'll just eat that
difference they're going to say I'm
going to have to apply that cost to
somebody else now and I think that's the
question where does the cost get applied
to because it's going to be rain neutral
representative
Bernardi so uh contemplated this issue
um I think we are dealing with uh about
100501 C4
institutions uh that this may be
eligible they may be eligible to use
this if they had lines that were single
service to well and or septic if they
don't have such a line they're not
eligible for any change in their in
their building
here uh so um when you look at what the
difference in the rates were and uh uh
Mr sweat presented some data here it was
around uh $2 a month so uh you look at
that and say how
uh we're at uh what
$240 a year for if all the uh groups in
the that are eligible had such a had
such a line uh you're you're now at uh
What uh uh
$20,000 that that would be shifted from
uh
from a commercial rate to a residential
rate so the utilities are out
$20,000 across all of New Hampshire I I
I think that amount of cost shifting is
in the weeds it is just non it doesn't
make any sense it's it's it's less than
Mills so yes indeed that $20,000 is
going to have to be distributed over all
residential customers in the state and
and that
is we wouldn't see it representative
Corman and and uh adding to
representative Bernard's point I think
it's actually going to be less than that
because
I think what we're seeing is uh
condo uh condos where many of the meters
are single unit and only some of them
are shared so I mean the total number of
meters that we're talking about in the
that Miss Stone you have anything to add
um I don't think so I think that was
that was all for thank you I understand
eversource may also have some concerns
with this language so I would invite
them to share those concerns with us if
much welcome back Mr
chairman I'm now properly a lobbyist
that um so thank you uh members of the
committee uh Griffin Roberge with
eversource energy yes uh eversource does
have concerns with the proposed language
mostly on sections um one and three um
you know eversource classifies service
to its customers as either residential
or commercial with different rate
options available within those each
within each uh broad rate class and
those rates are developed uh quite
equitably based upon the costs of
service to the different types of
customers um the language would uh here
appears to um give condo associations
the means to bypass the appropriate
process for rate designation um and
effectively in a way game the system as
a result of this you know there is the
potential as dewe mentioned for the
under recovery of costs and an
inequitable uh cost shift between
residential and non-residential
customers um I know there was some
discussion here a moment ago regarding
what that amount might be
I certainly couldn't put a number on
that but at least from a very broad
level we do anticipate that a cost shift
would occur here um we also do frankly
view this as respectfully a precedent
piece of legislation as you are
essentially giving a carve out to
certain entities to pick and choose what
rate classification they fall under um
it does you know open the door for
potentially future entities to come in
and maybe do the same you know we would
submit that respectfully customers
should not be in a role of making these
determinations there are metering and
Engineering considerations that need to
take place when it comes to uh rate
designations and we think that that is
appropriately you know set through you
know our tariff structure and how that
is all uh done over at the Public
Utilities Commission I do recall um
additionally that um there has been
discussion on a bill last year that was
in the house Commerce Committee that has
very similar language that there was a
non legislative solution to this I
believe there still is a non-legislative
solution to this um and we wanted to
certainly share those concerns here with
folks um you know before this bill kind
of moved forward um and I'll stop there
in case anybody has any questions so is
there specific language in this
amendment that could be changed to
resolve any issues you might have or do
you think this whole uh amend needs to
be thrown out so thank you for the
question I think our Focus would
certainly be on sections one and three
uh because that directly affects I think
our operations at ever Source I
respectfully don't want to be in the
position for speaking for Rural Electric
cooperatives Municipal Utilities and
that type of thing um regarding section
two you know looking at that a little
bit closely um that looks like it's a
requirement that's placed on condo
associations as to how um a bill would
be paid under this structure um you know
I think I did hear um representative
Corman mention that you know the condo
association doesn't have this provision
in their in their bylaws um you know
it's a question for the committee as to
whether or not they feel a legislative
language to cure this issue for the
condo association is feasible is the
appropriate path or whether or not the
bylaws anybody else have a question to
representative Cor
thank you Mr chairman um the the the
amendment is quite specific that we're
talking only about septic and well pumps
for residential units so I don't think
there's any ambiguity and any danger
here of it going to anything else in
terms of of trusting whether the
customer is truthful I mean you have to
do that already you know I'm I'm not an
eversource customer I'm a liberty
customer and Liberty believes me that I
am am a resident and not a business I
could just as easily be setting up a uh
a shop in my basement where I make boot
scrapers and sell them and turn my house
into a commercial entity and Liberty
would be none the wiser so I I think to
some degree if a condo association says
this meter is going only to residential
well and
septic I I think it behooves you to
believe them unless you have reason not
to
sure
uh I I guess I'll comment on that um so
you know again we do view it as frankly
a precedent that it even if it is
narrowly tailored it is essentially a
carveout for certain types of systems
that receive electric service um
obviously no current legislature can
bind the future legisl legislature so
you know this does open the door for you
know moving certain entities with with
unique rate classifications into others
um again you know the other thing I
would I would comment on is I do believe
that the condo associations uh pumps in
question here um you know they are
registered as a commercial Enterprise
with the Secretary of State um which
does label them as a commercial uh
entity um you know our tariffs also
include language that you know defines
how those um how those rate
classifications are offered out um you
know I just offer that I guess for the
committee's awareness and you know
obviously the legislature will do what
the legislature wants to do but
certainly again just wanted to share our
concerns with the
language representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Ro bear nice to see you again
good to see you um so I have two
questions uh you mentioned that a
similar B came up last year and that
there is a non-legislative fix so could
you inform us as to what that would be
would that be the utility taking some
kind of a making some kind of an effort
to assist these folks who our residents
sure and thank you for the question so
you know in looking at this you know
this condo association is not an
eversource customer the one that is the
focus of this bill obviously um there
are other conduit associations that we
provide service to what this bill's
impact will be to any other condo
association you know we'd have to do a
deeper dive but there is that potential
um regarding your um your question about
a non-legislative solution you know as I
think I heard there there might be a
solution there and I'm trying to
remember from last year but um the bill
did end up before the house Commerce
Committee It Was Defeated over there um
we do um we do feel that you know if
it's an issue of who pays what um you
know I think that's something that the
condo association would be able to
potentially work out with its own
members with its own uh condo unit
owners um you know I think respectfully
P moving forward a bill to create a
Statewide solution to what is an
otherwise localized issue could have
consequences follow up thank you Mr
chair um so the second thing is that you
had exception with the bolded language
on page two section three you didn't say
what specifically was that issue for you
I am very sorry say lines one more time
um section three you said you you just
generally said we have a problem with
Section one section three but can you
tell us what's wrong with section three
in your opinion yeah sure again it's
it's I guess as I mentioned earlier it
is creating that carve out essentially
for certain types of entities certain
types of service uh to be moved from One
Rate classification to another um I
understand that you know in the public
hearing that there was some debate as to
whether or not the uh use is residential
or commercial again we follow the
language under our tariffs this language
would essentially create a carve out and
allow people to move off of One Rate
onto
another correct that is the point of the
bill yeah no I understand and that is
our
concern representative Thomas has a
question Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair
um I understand your concern about um
that this is a precedent and that um
customers might start challenging this
but isn't wrong wrong if they're
classified in the wrong category and
they're paying more than they should
isn't it is it a bad thing for our
constituents to pay less sure and thank
you for the question so you know again
not our customer but you know could also
imp could impact condo associations
across our service territory um you know
I don't necessarily have a direct answer
to an equity question but you you know I
can only just speak to the matter at
hand is that the entity is a commercial
uh is registered as a commercial entity
in the state it is rightly charged
commercial rates um and again passing
this language would create a type of
carve out for a specific type of entity
um which you know kind of jumps over the
language that utilities have in their
tariffs which are properly adjudicated
and set up before the Public Utilities
Commission um through extended dockets
and proceedings so I'll leave it there
thank you you representative Harrington
has a question yeah I think getting back
to the non-legislative solution which to
me is always a preferred way of doing
things we have plenty of laws I don't
think we need more uh my understanding
would be if the condo association
rewrote their rules and simply said the
president of the condo association shall
be build for electric use for sore
common soore and water and the amount of
this bill should be distributed evenly
among all all condo members that would
take care of the problem because it
would be an individual's name in the
billing and the utility with then charge
the residential rate is that correct yes
that that is a potential path you know I
I'm you know obviously it's the condo
association to determine what path might
be suitable but I believe that there are
non-legislative solutions that could be
you representative McGee thank you Mr
chair so my question would be whether uh
whether eversource would be amenable to
that type of change because it would be
the same type of carot right because
currently the homeowners
association is already filed and and
dealt with as a commercial entity by the
utility so just changing who the bill
goes to that wouldn't necessarily assist
them with the rate correct uh not necess
I don't believe you're correct not
necessarily but again there is if there
is that rate change again going back to
what I said earlier there is that
potential for that under recovery of
costs and a cost shift to occur and an
undefined amount again I will admit I
don't have you know hard and fast
figures as to what that cost shift would
be okay I'll leave
it representative Corman thank you yeah
so during the subcommittee we had an
attorney here uh who really was against
the idea of trying to build any
individual uh unit owner for these
shared meters uh and even if it's the
president of the
HOA that's an individual rather than the
HOA itself doing the billing so I mean
imagine if you were the president of an
HOA and you have a unit owner who is
recalcitrant in actually paying and if
it's that they're not paying you that's
a very different situation from if
they're not paying the HOA sure and and
I I guess I would say you know again it
is up to a condo association to
determine if you know what PS what path
they would want to go down for any
potential non-legislative solution
whether that's moving the uh name of the
account uh from the condo association to
a resident and then splitting up the
costs um but again those are potential
solutions that could be could be done
non- legislatively um and don't need
okay Mr bro Burge thank you thank you
appreciate your
input so as I think about this issue my
mother-in-law lives in a
condo type uh development and she pays
HOA fees and I have read on her behalf
the HOA agreement rules
Etc and I'm having trouble figuring out
how is residential well and septic
although her Association doesn't have
either but how is that different from
for
example shared landscape services or
shared snow plowing
Services the
HOA pays for
those
and each individual resident pays their
share by paying their HOA fee
so wouldn't that couldn't that cover
these um these meter fees these well and
septic
fees if I may uh you may yeah thank you
uh yeah I I I don't think the analogy
quite works because we're talking about
meters that are
serving just residential units as
opposed to uh the the landscaping or the
laundry which is serving the
entire uh development we're talking
about meters that are serving in
individual you know like two units and
it's just for their residential use I
mean there's in in terms of of the use
it's really no different from if it was
a single meter for a single unit here
it's just a shared meter for for two
units but doing the very same thing so
taking that cost of that meter that
shared meter and and distributing it
over the entire condo doesn't seem to
make sense if you're going to do that
you might as well just take all the
individual meters and share them over
the condo which I don't think you want
to
do representative
bernardy yes uh thank you Mr chair I I
think if I understood your um
example the relevant uh issue would be
here if the landscape service or the
snowplow service said to the condo
association
uh our billing rate for you
is 50 bucks an hour but the house next
door since it's a residential unit we
build them 25 bucks an hour for
landscape work and and uh and for snow
plowing I think that would be the
relative you know uh circumstance that
that that would apply so this is an
issue of
being charged more be just because of
the name of on the bill as opposed to
is okay further discussion on
this all right seeing none we'll have to
decide later on what we're going to do
about all this but that was a good
discussion I think it explored all the
issues let's move on now to House Bill
266 which is a bill
that has turned out to be quite um
complicated and
controversial as the department of
energy and the Public Utilities
Commission kind of have a disagreement
about how to
handle adjudications so representative
Harrington has been sort of leading the
charge to try to come up with a solution
solution to this dilemma and I'm going
to let him explain what he's learned and
what he's come up with well what I
haven't learned is where my copies are I
don't know I sent a quest up to the
fourth floor and nothing's happened so I
don't know where where they were at uh
but I can read you what I what was
proposed
anyways um hang on a second
representative Matson has volunteered to
go up to the fourth floor to see if she
can find them so please do thank you was
just sen up well he's already gone
anyways
um there's there's kind of two issues
here the first one was who gets to
appear where and who makes that decision
and it appears as if the department of
energy has kind of conceded to the Pu
that they'll be involved in all cases
and it's the amount of that involvement
and how much they do that's still of
question I'll let the various uh parties
talk about this
a new issue has come up though and
that's the um right to appeal and
adjudication by the Pu by Doe and that
to me I'm not sure if it's it's a major
issue but it certainly brings up an
issue of having one state agency
represented by the Attorney General's
office suing another state agency
represented by a different individual in
the Attorney General office in the
Supreme Court uh maybe that's done a lot
I'm just not familiar with it but I I
just think it's an issue that would have
to at least be addressed to make sure
that that's okay to do so uh that's the
issues right now and uh and I I think
the individual people should probably
best speak from both the Pu and
Department of energy as to exactly what
their issue is on they could explain it
what their concerns are better than I
you so did you come up with some
language for House Bill 266 to address
this issue the latest version is what it
says it's added to uh section section
two and it says um uh the department
shall have the authority to petition any
proceedings before the Public Utilities
Commission and shall automatically be a
party to all proceedings that's that's
presently the way it says and then and
have full party status and the right to
appeal in any adjudicative or non-
adjudicative proceeding that's the new
that's new language and uh that is the
okay who do you suggest discuss that
language I would like to hear from the
Pu and from the Department of energy
okay representative Corman thank you uh
so representative Harrington just so I'm
clear here uh the the amendment you
filed uh restores The Struck uh text in
line 8 and removes the Bold text in line
10 is that correct yes it kind of goes
back to the way it was with the
exception of the sentence that I just
read so adding the Bold text in lines 8
and N but not in line 10 yes thank you
the but the new bold text that brings up
the right to appeal that's new I don't
know which version you have but
okay okay let's hear what the department
of energy has to say first then we'll
Pu good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee Matt Young um brother the
record my name is Matt Young an attorney
at the department of energy um apologies
I'm going to work off my phone for uh
the amendment text in the um Bill text
uh so
first
um representative Harrington's uh
correct that the uh the amendment would
leave in the uh be up the language in
section two which says that we would be
a party to all proceedings um and then
regarding the um language on the right
to appeal
uh I do believe that right to appeal
language was included in the int as
introduced um and I can help clean sort
of clear up the question about uh
appealing and kind of who's against who
and an appeal so in
um I guess thinking of the Pu sort of
like a court there's there's obviously
two parties one of which is the
department um and then uh you know
usually utility and I guess there could
be even more parties OCA uh any
interveners and when an appeal is made
it's an appeal of the Pu order
and um the party who is appealing is
appealing that decision and the other
party would essentially be defending
that position so it's not NE it's not a
lawsuit um sort of as described by
representative Harrington where it would
be doe versus um the Pu on an appeal
it's really just an appeal of that
decision um so I do hope that clarifies
that and then I guess also I would say
um the Department of Justice does have
representatives for each state agency so
in an event where a state agency would
um sue another state agency there are
representative councils from the
Department of Justice on either side of
that again that's that's not really what
what this would be um but just wanted to
point that
out okay anybody have a question for the
doe representative McGee thank you Mr
chair and thank you Mr Young for being
here again um I my question is really um
where the impetus for the bill came from
I'm just curious what you're hoping to
achieve I understand what the language
is asking us to um put into statute but
where did it come from what what was the
driving force in wanting to have a
legislative update
here so um it's really a clarifying bill
I think we sort of look at it um sort of
clar clarifying the status quo
um I think some of the uh important
language in there and again sorry
looking at my phone um language in
section one that uh just sort of
clarifies that uh we can complete the
record as determined by the department
um we sort of looked at that as uh the
word complete is could be you know what
is a complete record it's a little vague
um so it just allows the department sort
of determine what it introduces as
evidence in a pu
proceeding okay and but the language May
followup yes um oh yeah it's always
we're in a work session so it's just we
we're in we weird rules here um but the
section that uh representative
Harrington was referring to in terms of
the changes in section
three uh starting on line 8 that section
is a place where there's a little bit of
an additional there's a there's a the
right to
appeal uh was added so was there a
concern
with um was there a concern with an
inability to appeal or was there a
concern with uh judicative
results that needed to be appealed I
mean where did that come from so I I I
do recall that um I believe Deputy
Commissioner elm's testimony to sort of
speak to some of the bigger issues um I
think I can just point to that it's that
language really just just sort of
clarify the party status the full party
status of the department um when the uh
Department was created prior to that
there was some questions of P staff
involvement in the in the proceedings
and this just sort of
clarifies the distinction there oh and
have there been appeals in the
new I wouldn't want to speculate um I'm
I in in my time I'm trying to think um
but again this just sort of clarifies
what we to be true what we believe to be
true
now representative Harrington just so
we're clear on this then in the past
before the department of energy the
staff on the Pu worked for the Pu and
was part of the Pu so they very they
couldn't appeal a puc decision because
they were they were instrumental in in
making getting that decision because
they could speak to the U the
Commissioners exp partti actually and
that was one of the big reasons for the
reorganization so now you're saying that
the department of energy should be
acting independently and if they
disagree with a ruling by the Pu that
they would have the ability to appeal
that to the Supreme Court that's the
change correct correct and that's the
only change you're proposing in the
266 well I so I do believe that that
that language was included in the bill
as introduced yes but the the previous
the other changes you taking out so 266
remains it's the only change to the
existing law is this paragraph about
repealing appealing no it would okay
that's what I'm trying to get straight
no no it would be everything and then I
believe the Amendment language does just
uh
replace just the part of section two
leaving in everything else and but the
thing that does change in section two is
that the part the department will remain
a party to all proceedings okay so that
language is not struck okay that's not
struck but the rest of the 266 as
introduced is still in effect that's
what I'm trying to get straight I'm okay
because what it was sent to me I got
part of it and not the whole not the
whole bill so so we what I really would
like is if you could give us a copy of
what you're proposing the entire 6 266
okay whatever changes you want to see in
it because we get two pieces here and
it's kind of hard to match them up to
thanks and we don't have much time
because we have to have an amendment by
one o'clock
so uh representative Thomas uh Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um the Pu when
they testified they said that they felt
this bill would slow down
dockets um does this amendment um and
proposed change address that or if you
agree with that
statement
um so we would be a party to um with
this amendment we would remain a party
to all proceedings as as inquired so I
don't it doesn't really make changes to
the structure
of and and I will say Mr chair that uh I
do believe the language that was sent
would is an accurate Amendment that
would reflect ultimately what we would
want in the
bill but we'd be happy to provide the
full text of what we would like 266 to
look like to represent of Harington as
well unfortunately we don't have a copy
issue and representative Matson went up
to the fourth floor and there is no copy
up there correct no and she checked with
the
the who writes the Amendments and they
don't have any request for an amendment
s an
fromer all
right I guess we're gonna we're gonna
let the the Pu give us their take on
this amendment even though we don't know
what the amendment is
um and we'll just have to go from there
I guess so thank you Mr Young appreciate
it next we'll call up Mr ell from the
Pu I assume that you have received a
copy of the amendment is that would that
be
correct I hesitate to say that Mr
chairman Alexander spidel New Hampshire
P um it seems like this is a work in
progress but I can offer some conceptual
thoughts regarding the PC's positioning
on this General Bill and please and it
seems that the department is
contemplating further amendments as the
morning wear on so uh leaving aside the
exact language of the bill there's still
the resourcing issue that I believe I
wasn't here on last Monday but I believe
that chairman goldner talked about the
potential need to for additional
resources at the commission related to
this bill because there's not really an
understanding from the Pu side as to how
and when the doe will provide analytical
support so we'll leave that aside but
that's still a live issue for us the
other two live issues
I would say that the PC position is
developing where we're suggesting that
this could definitely use an interim
study type vehicle um a committee review
because I don't share attorney Young's
confidence that the puc decision will
not be supported by the Department of
Justice before the reviewing Court which
is the Supreme Court so I'll give an
example to my knowledge there has been
no doe appeal before The Supreme Court
of any P decision so it hasn't been
adjudicated since 2021
the most recent appeal that we can
definitely talk about is uh there was an
appeal by Liberty Utilities of the
Granite Bridge decision back in roughly
2019 2020 and that
decision in Conformity with the usual
practice of the Department of Justice
that decision by the P was being
defended at the Supreme Court by
Department of Justice
Personnel so uh the PC is not ready to
concede that there wouldn't be
Department of Justice support of the
agency's decision-making just like when
the department dep of safety makes an
adjudication at one of its hearings
certainly you have Department of Justice
support of that before The Supreme Court
so that's an open question for
consideration the other piece for
consideration is that
um I I wouldn't necessarily
expect that the department of energy
itself knows uh its procedural posture
in in every proceeding and it can get
complicated where you can have
situations such as uh the department of
energy is in partial agreement with a
given party on a decision but not in
full agreement so that's a gray area
that we think probably the the safest
ground would be for um this amended Bill
however it looks to be referred to a
study
committee interesting thank you
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr spidel for being here
this morning
um so we just had testimony from um from
doe that they're not talking about an
appeal to the Supreme Court or with or
with doj's involvement but rather the
ability for the Department of energy to
appeal decisions of the Pu in order to
sort of keep them moving or question
results or you know have some input to a
decision that they think is not uh in
the best interest or appropriate and as
the department of energy I think they
think they probably should be playing
that role so what you just talked about
was something much broader which is a
suit that was brought on on the granite
Bridge Project to the Supreme Court I
don't think that's what the doe is
asking for did you did you get that from
the testimony it it seems that way
because right now under the
administrative procedures act any person
may seek rehearing of the commission's
decisions before the commission itself
so there's uh administrative law there's
a concept called exhaustion of
administrative remedies so you have the
initial decision by the administrative
agency aka the commission then you have
a rehearing now if the re-hearing is
denied and the person or party is still
grieved including the department of
energy because they have sought
re-hearing of certain commission
decisions then you have a trigger where
they could go and seek appeal before The
Supreme Court and I think that's what
they're trying to nail down that seems
to be the case um in general terms
there is uh you know we're trying to
proceed with caution we're not saying
that this is completely uh out of line
we're just we're struggling with working
out all the details and we think that it
would be important to examine those
committee okay representative Thomas
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair
um previously when the Pu testified that
they they mentioned that this would
require more resources people hires um
and you just mentioned it as well and
yet there's no fiscal note attached to
this where's the disparity on
that I'm trying to jog my memory as to
whether number one the commission was
asked for a fiscal note and it may have
been marked as
indeterminant and so I I'm not certain
of that I would have to look that up
okay but you follow up um but you
definitely say that if this passes
people would be need to be hired well
the commission is concerned that if we
can't rely on an analytical product from
the Department of energy in these
situations that it would be prudent for
the commission to develop more internal
resources to address those issues okay
thank you this bill was introduced
without a phys fiscal note so I assume
that means nobody was consulted about
fiscal issues I I don't hesit I I I
hesitate to make that determination sir
I don't
know representative
Harrington the original bill which had
the department of energy making the
decision of which docket to join and
which one is not to has been changed now
the latest bill I believe doesn't that
discretion is not there anymore they're
they're me a party to all and so I don't
think we need the additional resources
in the Pu if the if the do de the
department of energy is going to be
there for every every issue because that
that's been taken out of the latest
version uh yes um I would say that yes
they're going to be present there but it
could just be a very minimal sort of a
chip on the bumper presence versus an
active presence I'm not s sure that it's
always going to be an active presence
followup yes followup they could do that
I mean today there's nothing specific
that tells them you will do whatever as
directed by the Pu they just they make a
filing and they can make it as comp Lex
or as simple as they decide
correct there's no statutory language
that informs them that you will provide
the Pu with what they request uh well
this is open to some discussion but the
12p statute says that there's to provide
administrative support to us in our
adjudications and that's being changed I
Believe by this bill if I'm not mistaken
okay we'll have to get the latest
version I thought that part was was take
was taken out so we'll have to get back
to the Department of energy on that if
version yes I think it would be useful
to get the latest version as soon as
possible so see if you
can see if you can make that happen
sooner rather than
later um I guess we're going to have to
suspend further discussion on this bill
I remember from the public hill before
you let you go though I do remember from
the public hearing that one of the
contentious issues here was that the
Department of energy did not want the Pu
to tell them what they had to do what
they were supposed to
do they did the the department wanted to
make that decision on their
own
and could you refresh my memory what
your reaction is to that request by the
department I wasn't there on Monday last
Monday but I've been involved in some of
the internal discussions regarding the
Department's bill and there's a level of
respect by the commission for the
Department moving in that direction but
we have to make sure that everything's
ticked and tied and clear and
furthermore uh it would be again wise
for the commission to say okay if the
department is going to do its own thing
and sail in its own Direction and I
believe that chairman goldner also
Express the position that you know he's
okay with our not being administratively
attached for the back office stuff
that the department helps us with now
it's okay if the puc handles that in
house but regarding the analytical work
we should probably staff up to a certain
extent and make sure that um that's
being adequately taken care of but it
seems like this is a little bit of a
moving Target Mr chairman where the
Bill's impetus or its uh points of
emphasis is changing a little bit and so
we're just saying okay we ought to know
where this lands and where it lands we
ought to have some input and discuss
all right well thank you I appreciate
that thank you Mr chairman all right
we're going to not discuss this bill
anymore because I I think we're not
going to be able to make much
progress so we're going to move
on Mr chairman just one final comment
representative and this was to the Pu
you realize that the latest version has
taken out that sentence about it put it
back in it says proceeding to all
parties having to deal with with the doe
back okay well we we'll get I assume
you're working on something over there
the doe right to get us a paper copy as
now representative Bernardi just
reminded me that OSS will not respond to
emails for amendments anymore you either
have to use the online portal I'm not
sending it to them to the people
upstairs oh you were sending it to
committee they didn't get it I've been
trying to send it to Robin so she could
do it and I keep getting rejected back
here I must be typing something wrong
whatever uh but her email address comes
back and just says it's not valid so I
don't know what's going on Davis if you
can help we'd we'd appreciate
it but it I will remind you
representative Harrington if the time
comes to go try to retrieve an amendment
from OS you can't do it via email you
have to do it either by phone by the bo
yeah the portal or in
person all right so let's move on and
and this bill is relative to utility
companies adopting Advanced meters the
bill is introduced was quite complex and
potentially cost ly so representative
McGee has come up with a an amendment
and
U I'm going to pass out this amendment
to everyone
here and then I'm going to turn the
floor over to representative McGee to
yours thank you Mr
chairman okay so
um the impetus of the bill is a is
another stab at the Apple from a bill we
put in last year um to try and get
at um having a plan around when we would
have advanced meter technology available
uh which will be enabling other
functionality that we're hoping to have
in the state of New Hampshire sometime
in the near future
um but what ended up happening is there
were a significant significant amount of
detail in the bill in terms of how um
meter adoption would occur who would be
responsible for paying for what portions
of that adoption and so it it's thought
to be you know extremely detailed and uh
in speaking with eversource about that
approach um it was really a non-starter
from their
perspective uh rather than have yet
another year roll off the calendar
without us making any effort uh to
secure additional information that's
basically needed by the state to support
other policies that we're entertaining
on this committee I uh pulled back
uh the direction of the bill so that
what it does at this point after the the
findings um I um put a new section two
starting at um line 19 access to
interval Advanced meter functionality
into it and
basically uh put in a section that says
that the electric distribution utilities
under commission jurisdiction that have
not implemented or not in the Pro
process of implementing interval and
advanced meter functionality capability
uh oh capable of reporting hourly
consumption or exports to the grid for
all or most of the distribution
companies for use and load settlement um
provide us with a report on their
compliance with the firk order
2222 uh by November of this year and
that is simply to help us get a sense of
since there is a federal order um
concerning grid
modernization and utilities um providing
additional functionality to support
distributed energy resources being added
to the system in a you know a systemic
way that all utilities have to um move
towards that or or uh provide some
planning in in terms of compliance with
that order and so I think we should be
able to be privy um to that information
to help us support the bills that we're
going to be writing for the following
year so November 1st is the deadline and
it's basically a report to this
committee and to the uh Senate energy
committee as
well okay thank you for that explanation
representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair so uh when
we had testimony on the original Bill
basically every utility had a problem
with it and every utility reported that
they Le best of my recollection had
plans for when they were going to
actually Implement uh you know uh time
of use meters and and and whatnot um so
are those plans that we heard earlier
not adequate for compliance with FK
2222 thanks for the question um I don't
think every uh utility had a problem
with the bill uh because I know unitel
already has Ami meters um and the co-op
already has Ami meters so in terms of um
more sophisticated data coming from the
meters it's not all utilities and uh we
have vague uh information about 5 years
out maybe eight years out for our our
largest eversource our largest um
utility company being able to um get to
the point where after there other
customers in the New England region
they've got plans I guess but they
haven't shared with us what those plans
are so in terms of an ETA it is a bit
vague and in terms of the federal
pressure uh to up upgrade um the
technology infrastructure in order to
enable uh wider scale adoption of local
sustainable sources
um I don't know how those two things go
together but I think that it we it we
legitimately should be able to ask and
get that answered that's what the bill
do so what would we then do with that
answer what would you prop propose to do
with the
answer well I think if we had uh greater
information about the intention
for for example the push back that we
get currently with some of the things
that we've asked to have happened are
that backend system upgrades the
technology on the backend systems which
in some cases are disjointed um and
older uh that's a a large scale
investment not going to happen anytime
soon but it's an inhibitor because it's
a it's a it's a technical component of
being able to move to a place where we
can actually do the reconciliation on
the bills and do the kind of load
settlement you know
sophisticated um
billing and um so we don't have any
insights into that they're private
company they're doing their thing but as
a state I actually think we've been
asking for a while to say okay you have
these roadblocks that you're saying are
insurmountable but you must have a plan
because we're not the only government
entity
that is applying pressure saying we need
answers we need to know how many years
is it going to be at what point are all
the technologies that required going to
be there are we looking
at are we looking at having all the
meters replaced in a five-year time
frame but still not having the billing
capability at that point and then that
project going from there we don't know
so we don't know what the answer is and
that means we don't know how many years
it's going to take for our our largest
utility to be able to provide um the
technical capabilities that are required
in a modern system and since the federal
government is requiring utilities to do
that I think we should we should ask to
be privy to the response of you know any
company that doesn't already have Ami
meters as to what what what their
responses are to the federal government
on that in that
cuz they're also asking
for
um they're also asking for the backend
uh capabilities not just the meter which
is basically uh the way you get the
information but also the processing of
the information so all of the things
that are preventing us from moving
forward with more sophisticated energy
transactions is are also covered by that
2222 um 2222
order which I have here if anybody's
interested in looking at it but um yeah
it's just it's just requiring that we
enable distributed energy resources to
come alongside traditional
resources um so that Reg Regional
organized wholesale markets can actually
H have a a systemic way of accounting
for those resources which right now it's
all peac meal and the federal government
is saying they're here to stay um and so
we want to be able to um streamline this
hard so would you be happy if the
November 1st report November 1st 2025
report said see our next integrated
plan uh I'm not I'm not aware if the
integrated distribution resource plan
includes um
um includes a the planning for the
upgrade of the backend
systems I I'm not aware of
that okay representative
Harrington yeah a couple of things first
I have no problem with us getting a copy
of the report but I did have a couple of
questions uh it says for all for
electric distribution utilities under
commission jurisdiction my understanding
was that this order only applied to uh
eversource because of size that say unit
until and Liberty were exempt because
they're smaller someone have to clear
that part up but my my major concern is
we don't have to do everything with the
law laws cost money this would have to
be go through the process voted on in
the house go to the Senate have hearings
in the Senate it's passes there then
it's going to go to the governor uh I
I'm assuming and I don't want to speak
for ever Source but I I'm assuming if we
said hey send us a copy of this report
will you that they would willingly send
us the copy of report without having the
power of of law behind it
it's a good idea but I don't think we
need a law to make it
work well let's ask eversource see what
they think um since they are here and
have a copy of this amendment let's see
what they think of this
amendment good morning Mr Lata thank you
for being here good morning uh Michael
Lata representing ever Source energy uh
we we did receive a copy of the amend
this morning and are uh sort of still
digesting I think we have a few concerns
with it uh the first is starting on line
seven uh section
two I guess we just disagree and believe
that that's not an accurate statement
that utilities uh do not accurately uh
settle load um as I testified to on
other bills uh that we do accurately
settle load today the contributions and
load reductions of uh a variety of of
Technologies are captured and shared and
any benefits of them are shared by all
customers um we also don't believe that
the current uh uh structure prohibits
demand lowering management by individual
customers uh there are a number of uh
demand response and de demand lowering
uh programs Place offered by all the
utilities uh so we we feel that those
aren't accurate
statements
um I guess what's being sort of tied
together here is um FK order
2222 and uh load
settlement uh and some presumed changes
or desired changes to the load
settlement process so um right now
Utilities in New Hampshire and I think
the vast majority in New England
regardless of whether or not they have
advanced metering Ami metering do not
use that hourly or five minute output in
terms of settling load they use what's
known as load shapes which are estimated
loads based upon the character of the
service um and so this bill seems to
intermingle those two issues so as uh
representative McGee spoke about FK
order 2222 what that really does the
goal of that is to allow aggregations of
small distributed energy resources to
participate in the wholesale markets
that is a different issue than load
settlement and I understand that there
is you know one entity in the state of
New Hampshire that has expressed
concerns and wants radical changes to
how all utilities settle load this seems
to be an intermingling of those two two
issues and so if I look at this
reporting requirement I've actually not
seen a b usually the bill requires you
know a state agency the department of
energy the Public Utilities Commission
the Department of Environmental Services
uh to submit reports to the legislature
this is asking the actual investor owned
uh
utilities uh to do so uh which is I'm
sure there are other examples of that
but a little bit unusual um here if I'm
reading this correctly um it would apply
to all utilities in New Hampshire I
believe because again uh even those that
don't have uh that do have Ami metering
I don't believe use those for load
settlement and so uh it's asking for the
utilities to report on compliance with
FK order
have the either don't have the inter
interval metering or Advanced metering
capable of allowing consumption uh for
all or most of their distribution
customers for use in load settlement um
again it's sort of tying together a
number of of different issues I'd also
point out there's been a lot of
conversation about per order
2022 um that this is actively being
worked on uh at the regional level and
actually all the different isos how to
actually implement this and the
implementation uh sort of requirement
for the utilities uh is in November of
20126 so this would essentially ask us
to report on an active ongoing Regional
discussion and I note
that lots of parties uh lots of
different entities uh are a party to
those conver ations uh if there is an
entity in the state of New Hampshire
that has questions or wants to shape how
that is implemented they have every
opportunity to do so uh instead of
coming to the New Hampshire legislature
and trying to change the law here to to
force issues when again it's very much
in flux there are regular meetings of
the iso metering group that are working
on this um so I I guess those are just
initial thoughts thoughts um uh with
this this is this is different than
asking the utilities you know what their
integration so if we were to pass this
legislation just a
theoretical what kind of report do you
think your utility would be required to
come up
with so I don't know where on November
1st of this year the regional
implementation process for for order
2022 would be I imagine it would
be just a brief update on where those
discussions
stand so following the normal course of
legislative
action if this bill passed this
committee or this amendment passed this
committee then went to the Senate
and the Senate agreed with it then it
went to the governor and she eventually
signed it and it took effect 60 days
after its Passage would there be enough
time that would take us into probably
August or maybe September would that
give you enough time to prepare a report
by November
1st I I imag I think the timeline in the
bill is is a fair point and I imagine it
would be a rather brief report for a
number of reasons the the just if I
point out just one more thing on the
finding section what we've seen is um I
I just urge the committee not to take
those words lightly um if you put this
into
statute these get these findings these
purpose statements they show up at the
Public Utilities Commission uh different
entities bring them forth and use them
to advance their um their individual
goals and so you're telling the Public
Utilities Commission of the State of New
Hampshire that the legislature has
reviewed the way that utilities
currently settle load and are
dissatisfied with it and would like to
fundamentally shift that presumably you
know you're comfortable with costs
associated with that and so we see that
these these you know people say ah
finding section that doesn't carry the
weight of law you know it's okay it's
just sort of a a a statement we we do
find that parties very much point to
this and uh it is in effect the
legislature telling the regulator
regulatory body what they desire as an
outcome so I I just urge you to really
consider whether you have a full
understanding of how load settlement
occurs today and how you would like to
changed representative McGee thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Lata I think
that's a fair point um on the finding
section um and I guess you know you and
I have had discussions we discussed this
specific bill um and what I continually
have tried to get at the chairman
mentioned earlier whether when the
integrated resource planning is done at
the Public Utilities Commission whether
there is an answer in terms of
planning when New Hampshire is going to
have when when ever source is going to
have the backend technical
infrastructure when are they planning to
upgrade their backend technical
infrastructure to
support stuff it doesn't support today
okay in terms of energy transactions and
and also uh on the meters you know we
don't have an answer for either of those
things and they're high level things and
that's really what what I'm trying to
figure out is what is the time frame for
New Hampshire to be able to
move um to really enabling a competitive
market and that that is something that
is of concern to this committee so every
time that issue comes up we don't get
any kind of an answer that there's no
plans that you know you need to do plans
so to the chair's question when you file
an integrated resource plan at the
Public Utilities Commission do you have
dates in there for a project plan that
is going to work on backend systems and
also the migration of the current meter
system so I I appreciate the question
and and I disagree that um we haven't
been forthright and provided in
information both to the legislature as
well as our Regulators on uh a a
timeline around Ami
transition um as we previously
discussed uh we did hire a third-party
consultant who specializes in this area
and and has worked in other just
jurisdictions on um the conversion from
uh AMR metering to Ami metering uh they
conducted what is was termed an Ami
feasibility study obviously we know it's
it's quite feasible it was really a cost
and benefit um analysis and it was a
cost and benefit analysis that looked at
this specific issue what is the optimal
time what is the optimal time frame for
eversource in New Hampshire PSNH to
transition from AMR meters to Ami meters
and what that that uh study which was
over 100 pages long was delivered to our
reg
Regulators both the department of energy
as well as the Public Utilities
Commission and you know I I know others
have referenced it and so they're
certainly aware of it and have reviewed
it uh showed that the the optimal time
is to begin that transition in
2030 uh in terms of replacement of our
systems in terms of where uh the
existing AMR
uh meters would be towards the end of
their useful life to limit uh the the
stranded cost Associated and I will
point out as well um we were asked to
run a scenario or the third party
consultant was asked to run a scenario
uh because I know we have been
criticized for installing AMR meters and
not going straight to Ami said well
assume you never installed any AMR
meters that you had the old radial that
uh meters that someone had to walk up um
and it did not show a significant uh
savings on the timeline or or really uh
moving that much faster so uh so that
has been delivered that is a document
that that folks have um we did not
include uh sort of this this planned
change over to to Ami in this most
recent rate case that's currently
pending again out of consideration for
cost and wanting to focus on that that
thoughtful planned optimized scenario
and the other piece of the question is
the other part that would be needed
would be the backend systems that seem
to be so so an issue yes so that
um uh that study included the entirety
of the universe of systems at ever
source that need to be changed and
converted to enable the implementation
of Ami from our our communication
Network to our meter data management
system to the billing systems the the
entirety of it so to be just to clarify
so what you're saying is that the
optimal time frame to begin the project
is five years from now and that's for
all of it there's not going to be
anything done in the interim for the
backend systems or it's all going to be
done at the same time and how long will
it take to complete do you know that
sure I'd be happy to provide a a copy of
the report um um I don't really want to
read a 100 Pages uh fair fair fair
enough I am sure that there
are um there is work that will be done
in preparation you just don't sort of
flip a switch um there are rfps we have
to put out there are are different
vendors we need to select um but I
believe the beginning of the conversion
including the the the uh back office
systems the uh uh Building Systems uh
2030 okay thank you very much I
appreciate you uh giving those giving us
those clarifying comments as the
facilitator of this work session I'm
going to move along because we need to
be ready
to uh adjourn the work session at 11:30
so that we can have respective caucus
meetings before lunch so let's move now
to a discussion of the next bill on the
schedule which is House Bill 759 FN
relative to community energy
generators
and there is no proposed amendment at
the moment for this bill so we're
talking about the bill as
introduced
and I want to express that I have a
serious concern
about the definition of community
generator which starts on line three of
introduced the definition definition of
community generator on line three see
says Community generator means a
customer
generator and then goes on from there so
that raises the question does a
same is it treated the same as a
customer
generator so for example would a
community generator be able to net meter
the way a customer generator
can because the definition definition
goes on to say
that the capacity at the point of
interconnection with the distribution
grid can be up to 5
megawatt and that's a
substantial
expansion of a definition of some entity
that could potentially net
meter and even if it wasn't net
metering the fact that there
are probably 60 to 70 Community
aggregation
communities in the state today could
potentially expose the state to an
increase in distributed energy projects
of about 325 to 350 megawatts which is a
lot and as FK has been telling us or
nerk rather has been telling us for the
last three years in a row the
proliferation proliferation
proliferation
apologies of distributed energy
resources is one of the Prime reasons
why our grid is becoming less and less
dependable and
reliable so I'm finding it very
difficult to um see
that this nit bill would be useful to
the state at this point in time it has
lines 14 and 15 it talks about rate
maximum rated export
capacity and the question was asked at
the public hearing does that mean the
same thing as name plate and if not why
has that change been made or if so why
has that change been
made there was also some question about
uh the text on line page two on line
nine about line loss adjustments being
assumed to be 1/ half of the utility
published distribution system line
losses which seems arbitrary and would
seem to beg for a line loss
study this whole bill would seem to
be an effort to bypass ISO wholesale
Market
jurisdiction and this topic is currently
being debated before the Pu so this bill
I think has many many flaws and while I
understand that the community aggreg
ators would like to see
uh some movement
on a definition of something similar to
a community generator we had this bill a
similar Bill last year I don't think
this bill cuts the mustard for this year
and that's my assessment and I'm anxious
to hear what other people have to say
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman uh I actually have an amendment
here that addresses some of the concerns
you just raised uh it
restores the original language that was
that was struck from section two about
total Peak generating capacity and
removes the part about maximum rated
export capacity at the point of interne
with the distribution grid so it just
restores that language that was there
and also it deletes section four about
um the line loss adjustments it does not
address your concern in section one but
I'm happy to pass it out out the other
thing that I would suggest is that we
invite um Mr Belo and Miss uh Dennis uh
to join us because they're very familiar
with this bill and may be able to
discuss some of your
concerns thank you further discussion
representative McGee yeah I'd just like
to add I know you and I had the
conversation about uh whether or not
it's um it's confusing to the issue to
have a customer generator as well as a
community generator so I went back and
made myself more familiar with this bill
which I wasn't really very familiar with
the bill and I think it's an attempt to
clarify that there are generators who
are aggregating and generators who are
acting to uh create supply for
municipalities that need to be
distinguished from customer generators
cuz customer generator is a category
that that covers the smaller and this is
this is its own category so I think it
clarifies um Us in statute to be able to
in our Mind's Eye when we're in front of
the Pu or when we're in these hearings
to distinguish what a community
generator is which is a larger entity uh
that is actually supplying a different
benefit right they're um they will have
interconnections which is something that
all customer generators don't have to do
uh and you know so there's a and they
and they'll be reducing load in a more
significant way so I think I think I
just wanted to say that about your
concerns about whether it is confusing
to have a new category I think the the
reason for the new category is pretty
well Justified we have different types
of people doing different types of
projects and they're not and if we call
them all customer gener generators then
it is more confusing for us to
understand what what scale we're talking
about in my
opinion well thank you for your opinion
that um this amendment does address as
representative Corman said some of my
concerns but my biggest concern is the
statement that a community uh generator
can produce up to five megawatts that's
that's a huge expansion uh of
distributed energy resource deployment
and I think that's just too much further
discussion representative migy yeah on
that point I know it's a utility project
but the the um project that Unitil is
doing in
Kingston um wouldn't that qualify as a
community generator project up to 5
megawatts I I mean I think people are
looking to do these projects so
I'm um
qualify okay no that's true
representative Harrington yeah I'm still
kind of bouncing through these and all
the terminologies and everything but
we're talking about Community General
and we have the let me start with this
the the uh the representative corman's
Amendment changes paragraph 2B but not
2G is that correct okay
um so there seems to be some confusion
because in 2B in the proposed new
Amendment says eligible customer
generator a a customer generator means
an electric blah blah blah up to
including one megawatt except for a
municiple host and then in 2G it talks
about it there's no one megawatt it's
just up to five and only for the load
being used for a municipal or County
aggregation and I thought the net
metering stand allowed up to five for
municipal or County use not a no one
else but those so I'm a little confused
here what's going on maybe someone can
enlighten
point Mr Belo would you like to
clarify uh what you intended when you
um as provided in the bill last year
that passed uh unanimously from this
committee um it does put the municipal
or I should say community generator
within the net metering framework so by
saying it is a customer generator it's
saying this is within the net metering
construct um there's no jurisdictional
issue of concern about uh the net
metering construct what this is is an
alternative to the municipal host
construct which is up to but under 5
megaw
um in which as a practical matter all
those projects have relied upon uh the
income from the distribution utility uh
as being compensated under the net
metering terms of the utility this would
and and they's concerned about the cost
shifting or issues around uh these
projects between one and 5 megawatts uh
that the utility is providing all the
compensation for in this case in the
construct of a community generator they
would not be participating in net
metering with the distribution utility
so there wouldn't be compensation for
their energy or capacity from the
utility but rather that would have to
come from uh the uh entity that they're
a customer of either a community power
aggregation or competitive supplier um
so in that sense it's it's a it's an
alternative to the municipal house
construct which is up to 5 megawatts I I
think that's the main point and it
doesn't involve the utility paying them
uh the default service rate um so
uh and it just it it's simply you know
for instance in the case of the city of
Lebanon we just want to be able to use
the output from our landfill gas project
which is base load so it's 247 almost
year round uh as a great resource rather
than selling the power to Liberty
Utilities we' just like to be able to
use it uh for Lebanon Community power um
it's it's sort of that
simple I guess I'll stop there see if
there's other questions that I can help
with okay so you're saying
that when we created the municipal host
legislation part of the impetus for that
was to provide savings for
taxpayers uh are you saying that this
community generation because it only
serves a community aggregation would
also provide savings for
taxpayers um well yes if as long as the
taxpayer uh wants to buy their power
from the community power and if they
believe that or if it is a better deal
than the utility any One customer is
still free to switch back to the utility
so these projects would have to be
vetted um and sort of judiciously
undertaken to ensure that they're uh uh
financially reasonable and sustainable
on a long-term
basis but because the utility
doesn't own the generation
facility um as it might under a
municipal host situation uh wouldn't
taxpayers not get any return from this
well well the utilities don't own
Municipal host projects um those are all
privately developed if I said utilities
I meant municipalities oh um well yes so
Lebanon would benefit by having a uh a
reliable Revenue stream for that project
for instance rather than just
speculating on what default Service
rates might be over the next 10 or 20
years and that would translate into
savings for taxpayers yes okay thank
you representative Harrington yeah it's
so many terms here it gets a little
confusing what is it that's not in the
law or is in the law that prevents this
from happening now what what's the
what's the roadblock that we're trying
to get
around um well first of all uh there's
no uh provision um that a com a
competitive electric power supplier or
Community power aggregation could be a
direct off-taker of anything uh over one
megawatt in
size I mean I thought municipals were up
to five up to but under the municipal
host construct which which is the the
participants in that group are not
off-takers they don't get credit for the
power supply all they get is a financial
credit which which is sort of the
difference between what the developer
needs to make the project pencil and
what they can get in revenue from the
utility default service um we do not
anticipate that we would pay as much as
the utility pays uh for just the energy
component
uh the equivalent of our default Service
uh but what we can offer is a longterm a
longer term uh uh more reliable uh rate
structure which works to the advantage
of developers because they have better
financing options follow up yes follow
and so what needs to be what's what's
preventing you from doing this right now
that's what I'm trying to determine well
the you can only do it as a municipal
host okay and you're not an off-taker
it's just sort of a a financial Kickback
to the accounts that sign up to get a
credit uh for the project but these the
second amendment that came out here the
newest one uh that basically says up to
five for a municipal house but up to one
for everybody else no um
because the it says what it does which
is in the current law uh says um it's
limited up to and including one me
megawatt
um except as provided for municipal host
and for Community generator so if you
look at the municipal host definition in
the statute it's very similar to the
definition for community
generator except for this structure
where you're not a direct off-taker it
doesn't provide for direct oftaking of
the power except really by the default
uh by the uh distribution utility so in
the definition of community generator
which would remain as part of the bill
it allows that a commun Community
generator could be up to but not you
know under under 5 megaw and a community
generator is not necessarily owned by
the
municipality correct correct so that's
yeah so that would seem to uh violate
the spirit of Municipal host then if uh
the municipality is not involved in
the ownership of the deer well they
could be involved in the ownership under
Municipal host they don't have to own it
either they can just contract for it
Municipal host projects are mostly being
developed uh not by municipalities but
by private developers or its existing
hydros between one and 5 megawatts that
are owned by for-profit corporations
that are converting to Municipal host
status and getting paid by the utility
at the default service
rate okay representative McGee thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Belo for being
with us again and enlightening us as you
always do um I'm looking at some of the
notes from the hearing on this bill and
I know when clean energy New Hampshire
testified um Sam Evans Brown had called
it an elegant solution to the problem of
aggregation and I think he was referring
in his answer to the fact that the
concern of cost
shifting um that has come up in this
committee so many times was something
that was solved here so can you say a
little bit about that because if it's a
benefit to communities to have more of
these projects to lower costs but it
also doesn't involve cost shifting then
I think we need to make that
clear
right um so part of the definition um
that remains in the bill under section
one of the bill uh still provides that
uses its excess generation to offset the
load obligation of a municipal or County
aggregation or a competitive electricity
supplier insight the two rsas under
which they exist um and
uh and obviously any of the load uh that
is being offset has to be in the same
electric distribution utility service
territory very much parallel language to
the municipal host construct um except
the difference is to enable this to be a
direct off-taker uh the the competitive
power supplier or the CPA um so what
that means is that this bill does not
you know would create an opportunity
that is outside of the project being
signed up for net metering with the
distribution utility instead signing up
for net metering with the competitive
power supplier or uh the CPA and one of
the things that's really important to
understand is for Liberty and Unitil is
there W won't be an opportunity for
smaller deers to participate the iso New
England Market because they're not
required to enable that um so that's not
really an option either at at at a
certain smaller scale
um and the
the uh project 4.9 megawatt project that
Unitil is doing in their case at the
Pu they pointed out that there are
opportunities for many additional
similar size projects that produce net
value for New Hampshire rate payers net
positive value eversource in their
current distribution rate cases said
they're looking to do a number of these
projects under 5 megawatts functioning
as load reducers that they want to
invest in because they believe it can
produce net savings for New Hampshire
residents so the question is why are we
enabling the distribution Monopoly to
develop these projects but not in
enabling other parties to develop them
manner okay quickly please thank you but
well the last question goes back to
something that the chair had mentioned
earlier was the perception that having
more of these projects might make us
more brittle or less uh stable and I I I
think you're as close to a subject
matter expert as we have so perhaps you
could speak to that concern um well sure
um as a couple of recent affer
Commissioners former chairman
uh uh uh wellinghoff and um um oh no I'm
blanking on his name um
pardon no the one who is a chief of
staff for uh um uh speaker uh not Mr
McConnell
um
um um doesn't matter go on a republican
former chair recent chair of for will
allow it cliff and a Democrat yeah
getting old um they jointly put out an
article saying there should be
bipartisan support for better enabling
distributed energy resources because
they can be developed quickly and
particularly if we enable storage to go
with them they can be much more reliable
in terms of their production which was
the intent of the maximum rated export
capacity but that's being taken out but
I will just say that language came right
out of the model de interconnection
standards by Iraq and has been a sort of
a topic of discussion at the doe but
they basically says well we can't
consider anything other than maximum
rated output because um because of it's
in the law so setting that aside though
the concept which still can exist um
because the problem is when you add
storage it also has a rated out export
capacity but its purpose is to help clip
for instance in a solar project store
some of that power that's being produced
at around solar noon and Export it in
the evening when it's more valuable and
for a competitive power supplier or CPA
would be evaluating the production
profile and wouldn't want to buy
something that's just producing power
when it's least valuable around solar
noon so I think this would drive
projects that are more optimal
investments just like Unitil argued um
in the CA in their case because it's
it's a better investment because it is
designed um with these temporal values
uh in consideration which is I think
what would occur with this okay now
we're going a little off uh course but
um one quick question can't the city of
Lebanon just sign a PPA with uh or the
can't the community power corporations
just sound a PPA with the city of
Lebanon to buy that
gas um or electricity
um right it could but we couldn't
compensate them for it because we get no
credit for those exports we pay P the
exact same amount money for our power
supply with or without it so so there's
no rational basis for us to compensate
them the utilities can compensate them
because by law they're allowed to
recover that and they recovered it
recover that cost by putting it in their
stranded cost recovery charge we we
don't have that
option okay all right we've got to move
on because if we're going to get done um
we've got quite a few more bills to
discuss thank you I appreciate that
clarification
so let's move on next to House Bill
storage so this bill according to the
prime
sponsor who was representative Corman
simply allows
uh net
metered generation to be time shifted
instead of putting it on the grid as
it's created by your solar panels you
can put instead you can put the the
energy into a battery and then put it on
the grid
later uh from your battery so it's it's
simply according to the bill allows
uh a shift of when you put the net
metered power onto the
grid however the doe had
some structural concerns about the build
they say it needs changes to the net
metering statute to make this
work
um so there seem to be some concerns
about whether this will work or
not so I'm
wondering if there's anything else we
here representative Corman yeah I do
have an amendment a very simple
amendment that um it just deletes
section three leaves the rest Alone um
so that uh I mean the commission already
apparently has that Authority and uh
Amendment okay so the rest of the bill
would be just the same that's
correct okay all right well we'll do
deal with that at executive session
755 this is a big monolithic bill that
Parts the DOA said that there are open
dockets before the puc that cover many
of the topics implemented by this bill
and that there are cost shifting
concerns Unitil opposed the
bill it was concerned about cost being
an issue because of system integration
expenses they wanted to wait for the
ongoing pu dockets and they also
expressed a concern about cost shifting
the Electric Co-op opposed the bill due
to
costs they testified that they tried to
implement a transactive Energy System
and failed and had to drop the
project and they also testified that
people don't seem to be all that
interested in time of use rates
eversource opposed the bill because it
dramatically changes load settlement to
benefit one group uh at Great cost to
others and it's a major change change to
definitions uh so there were
significant objections to this
legislation and
um it being so large and making so many
changes uh it just doesn't seem to me
that we can move forward with a a
monolithic Bill like this other reaction
representative McGee yes thank you Mr
chair um well I understand that the bill
is ambitious in terms of the scope of
what it covers um I on Friday we
received a notice from the Public
Utilities Commission that uh one of the
dockets I believe it was de
22060 that was to
cover um forward-looking aspects of the
distributed utilities compensation for
de and the net metering tariff all
things that we've been waiting for and
now that docket started three years ago
but there was also the VD uh which took
five years before that to answer some of
these questions um we got an order uh
that said that the docket was going to
be basically dissolved and put into an
investigative uh status which does not
require any any output so we we don't
have any further understanding of
whether a decision is ever going to come
out on those ending pieces
um of the adjudicative proceedings so I
guess the I I do understand
that uh folks in the competitive market
who are you know most amply represented
I guess by the community power Coalition
because they've you know they've taken
what we did in in hb35 and run with it
trying to you know become actual
competitors um
they have helped with some of the uh
legislation this year in terms of
understanding the nuances that we do not
in trying to get those things
represented in statutory language while
I understand that this particular one is
about reforming the market and it covers
a lot of items that are um that we we
don't have the answers to them I don't
think it's a I think the appropriate
thing for us to do would be to take this
to a study commit comme because at this
point uh we are we don't have any
answers coming from the Public Utilities
Commission and we keep sort of punting
it back and forth you know it's chicken
and egg oh well they're doing it so we
don't have to do it and they're not
doing it so I I think we do have a
responsibility to try and figure this
out and try and take whatever steps we
can to prevent further delay in anything
that we can um implement or or at least
understand better as a committee in
terms of bills for next year because
time is going by like I said we've we
wanted to understand the value of
distributed energy everyone was waiting
and I remember when we were putting off
Legislation during that period saying
wait until the report comes out and then
the report came out and the Pu decided
that they're going to look at it again
so we had the answers and we didn't you
know we didn't use them and then this
doc ET uh that was just dissolved on
Friday through an order was developed at
that point to say that the puc would
give us some answers on the tariffs um
and on what the valuation should be and
on how competitive markets should go
forward well they they're still waiting
and I don't see anybody actually um
giving us the answers so I think maybe
okay representative Corman thank you
yeah I agree this is a a large and
ambitious bill um and I can understand
reluctance to just charge full steam
ahead with it um and I agree with my
ranking member that a study committee
would be appropriate here so that we can
actually really understand the issues
out okay representative
Harrington yeah uh going along with the
kind of the same thing with a little bit
of confusion there's also a major part
of the bill is uh pursuant to the
relevant ISO New England tariffs and
procedures that take effect on November
1st 2026 we're supposed to do a lot of
stuff we don't know what those are yet
so I just think it would be rather uh uh
not the smartest thing to do to say well
we're going to we're telling you go
Implement something that we don't know
what it is yet because uh I think I
would like to see that tariff before I
I'm advocating not passing the bill at
least
so all right see no further discussion
on this bill we have one more that we
want to talk about a little bit and
that's HB
760 uh I know a lot of people have
gotten a lot of emails about hb7 to 60
and um I would just refresh everyone's
memory that ever Source opposed
this bill due to the ongoing docket at
the
Pu and
it Constellation Energy supported the
dock the bill um made a suggestion that
on line three the word should should be
changed to
shall and
um my notes say that there was a
suggestion that lines 18 and 19 section
two which is a
repeal be removed from the
bill
so there are some open questions about
um and I'd be interested to hear if you
have anything you'd like to say about it
representative
Harrington yeah I mean uh the concept of
the bill I like I think it's a good idea
if people get off default service
they're off default service they
shouldn't reap any benefits or penalties
based on what default service does if
they're no longer associated with it but
we did hear the Pu come out and saying
they have an extensive doet which I
think is going to be released issued
this spring and I just think it would be
imprudent on our part to put something
in the statute and then have the Pu come
up with some great other position that
maybe we say well boy that's not such a
good idea so I would like to hold the
bill an interim study until we get the
Pu ruling out and we can review that but
I mean personally they're going to have
to convince me
that this isn't a good idea because
that's where I'm coming from right now
but I'm going to I'm willing to give him
that
opportunity I think retain sounds like a
reasonable option for this bill
retain well retain an interim study can
be similar an interim study
recommendation is actually made in the
second year of the
banum and um in the first year of the
banum retain would be the would it be
the preferred Amendment apparently we KN
now have a an amendment for HB 760 so
let's hear what representative Corman
has to say about it thank you uh so this
amendment first of all it strikes uh the
section two from the original Bill the
repeal section so I know there were
concerns expressed about that it
clarifies in several places that we're
uh where we're talking about default
service we mean utility default service
so the word utility has been added in I
think four different places in section
one to just clarify we mean utility
default service
and uh there had been some concern about
the uh recovery period being uh no more
than a year so what this amendment says
is that um the period would be as
approved by the commission we'll we'll
that um and you know one one thing I do
want to say about the concept of the
bill and and we've discussed this
already the idea that if there are under
collections which we have a real danger
of having given that the Pu is pushing
the utilities to go to spot markets so
they really could be under
collections
that the that should really come out of
only the default service customers if
you're
on community power or competitive
supplier you should have nothing to do
with paying for those under Collections
and I say that as someone on default
service I mean it's you know it means
that I may end up paying more um but
it's the right thing to
do thank you for this amendment any uh
questions for representative Corman
about the
amendment representative Mickey
and as I'm glancing at the language does
this uh new bolded language actually
help us clarify that piece that you just
articulated does it does it ensure that
we're not uh having folks outside
default service paying those charges
right well I mean it makes clear that
the default service we're talking about
is utility default Service uh so in in a
clarifies
okay anything else representative
schneller thank you Mr chairman uh my
question is and and I support the bill
uh and I think the amendment is a good
one my question is does this address
commercial customers which I think are
substantially impacted by underc
well I'll defer that to representative
Corman um I mean I I don't know how the
rates are set so you know this is this
is outside my realm of expertise right
this is
um talking about the the under
collection so I I don't know if there
are separate buckets for residential
versus commercial in terms of of how the
collections are
you all
right so I think we we've gone through
all the bills now that we are going to
be executing this afternoon so I think
we
can shut down this work session unless
anybody has anything else they would
like to uh address representative
Harrington yeah on HB 266 I have a it's
a draft amendment that puts in the all
the different newest changes this is the
updated version I'll be handing it out
shortly uh there are some changes on
there where uh well I'll let people read
it when it gets out I'll have it out in
a second
so is this an actual Amendment it it's
an amendment uh this is what's being
proposed by the department of energy who
proposed the original Bill they've made
some changes in it and like I said I'll
let people read it and then we can
discuss it I can have it out in about
two minutes
people okay please hand it
time all right so we will after we have
this a brief discussion about this
amendment to HB 266 then we will break
for uh essentially a an extended lunch
break and the Republicans will stay in
this room to caucus so everybody else
will will need to leave at that point
but you don't need to leave until we
is there a version headed toward this
table this is not this is not going to
so this is a this is text that's being
proposed for an amendment and you're
going to go get it during well if we see
what people think of it I'm gon to ask
I'm going to ask the department of
energy to explain the changes and then
uh people can ask questions or whatever
and if they like it we'll bring it to
os does everybody have a copy yet
there's not enough okay well I've got
more
coming I write the number in on the fill
because
on everybody have one now everybody have
one
okay so representative Harrington take
us through it again okay so this made
some changes to the changes and some of
them went put things back the way they
were so it's it says at the top the
department H Authority investigate any
matter related to statute it administers
and then it going down to there's no
line numbers on this but the end of the
first paragraph it says and for the
purposes of providing instead of
complete it just says a record uh by the
commission as determined by the depart
department so that's that would be a
change and there's also the statement is
now back in that says and shall have
full party status and the right to
appeal any adjudicative or non-
adjudicative proceeding moving down to
section three um the words all necessary
are taken out ensure that the department
provides support required by so forth so
all necessary is taken out down to
section four talks about specific
answers the department and then gets rid
of all the commission may require any
public utility um to provide documents
and other materials and then again the
well on the second to last line of that
paragraph it says upon which the
department may need information within a
time period set by the department so the
commission was taken out there as well
and I'd like to request that the
representative from the Department of
energy explain why they need these
changes Mr
young as quickly as possible please
excuse me Mr CH we also probably should
hear from the Pu if they have objections
to them as well this is the first time
they've seen this do you have a copy Mr
SPID you have a copy great thank you Mr
Young thank you Mr chairman um again for
the record Matt Young attorney for the
New Hampshire Department of energy um
right off the bat I'll just point out
that um just to Super simplify this um
this document in front of you the only
change that's being made to the bill is
introduced is in section
two and the only change that's being
made in section two is that the language
that says we will be um a party to all
proceedings is being left
in that is the only change to the bill
is introduced um oh I guess I will say
there's there was language um removed at
the at the end there that just would
have been needed if we weren't being a
party to every proceeding but we are so
that was taken out as well so there's
some high there's a lot of highlights
here a lot of bold and cross outs the
only change to the bill is introduced is
that we are leaving in party tall
proceedings
hope that helps Mr just add so everyone
knows where that is it's line two of
section three correct very end of that
two okay thank you Mr spidel do you want
description yes please do thank you Mr
Young could I could I clarify one other
aspect before I leave or
okay what is it um so I just wanted to
clarify the uh the right to appeal
language that was brought up earlier um
and that that that's in the line three
of section
two um Mr spidel earlier referenced um
you know an instance where it might be
an issue where that the two um the doj
would appear and uh at the Supreme Court
I believe he mentioned the Liberty case
uh that that Liberty did appeal um and
the uh doj did represent the department
at the Supreme Court the p he was not
involved in that so I just wanted to
kind of clarify that
um when any party whether it be the
department or utility or the OCA or
anybody appeals an order from the Pu
it's not a lawsuit against the Pu it's
an appeal of the order the party who is
appealing the order would then would
obviously argue against the order and
the other party who isn't appealing the
order would defend that order because
they you know benefit in whatever way um
so I just want to make sure that was uh
crystal clear for the committee um and
questions okay I don't see any further
questions so now I'll ask Mr spidel to
go
ahead I'm I'm not jumping to the
conclusion that this is an official
amendment I think it has to go through
the legislative channels but reacting to
the language of the commission will rest
on the recommendation that this be
referred to some kind of study committee
we have to get through all this and uh
I'd been involved in the commission
almost a decade before attorney young
had been and I can say that there is a
discussion of the chairman of the
PC the Department of Justice regarding
defensive approaches to defending the
order or defending a decision of the
commission so the question that's
brought up by this bill is how does the
Department of Justice
react in a
scenario where the department of energy
is seeking an
appeal of a commission decision a
commission order
I think that's a very weighty question
that needs to be considered carefully
through a study committee vehicle and so
that's what uh I would offer
to this Committee in in reaction to this
lays language thank you okay thank
you seeing no questions we'll move on I
think we have it all under control at
this point so I'm going to bring this
work session to a
close and ask everyone to vacate the
room so that Republicans can
caucus I also will ask everyone to
return here at 1:00 for an executive
you
e
please take your seats we'll begin in a
minute
okay we're here for an executive session
on 10 bills this uh afternoon we have
some folks sitting in for some folks who
can't be here so for representative
Kaplan today we have representative
Sebert welcome thank you and for
representative Swanson we have
representative
Foss nice to see you and then for
representative Summers we have
representative
KH so thank you to the three of you for
being willing and available to be a sub
here on our for our deliberations this
afternoon we're going to take these
bills in roughly the order that we did
them at this
morning's work session so we're going to
start with House Bill
450 so I will open an executive session
450 which is a bill relative to
commercial property assessed clean
energy and
resiliency otherwise known as C
Pacer and as the prime sponsor of that
bill I move itl and recognize chairman
Vice chairman Thomas
second moved and seconded that we adopt
the motion of itl on House Bill
450 the reason we can do this so easily
is because we already passed this bill
we passed Senate Bill four which was the
Senate version of this bill that had a
couple of small changes that were
improvements to the bill we passed it
the house passed it and the governor has
already signed the bill so it is now
existing law so we no longer need this
house bill is there any further
discussion
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role in the question of itl on
House Bill
450 VI your Thomas
yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee yes representative
parall yes representative Sebert yes
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas yes
sorry Wendy Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
representative La Rochelle yes
representative fos yes chairman Vose yes
180 by a vote of 18 to zero the
committee adopts the motion of itl on
House Bill 450 without objection it will
go on the consent calendar I will write
the majority report or the U committee
report and that concludes the exec
session on House Bill
450 next we open an exec session on
House Bill
680 and I recognize representative
Harrington for a
motion move
itl I recognize represent resentative
Matson I second it moved and seconded
that we judge
hb680 FN to be which is uh relative to
standardizing homeowners association
electricity billing for shared meter
usage to adopt the motion of
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the question call the roll on the
question of itl for House Bill
680 rer Thomas yes represent n yes
represent Harrington yes represent Bry
yes represent Bernardi yes represent PL
yes representative Khan yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative
McGee yes representative parshall yes
representative Sebert yes representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
representative La relle yes
representative fos yes chairman Vose yes
180 by a vote of 18 to zero the
committee adopts the motion of itl on
House Bill 680
FN without objection we'll put that on
the consent
calendar hearing not objections so be it
representative Harrington will write the
committee
report and with
that we close the exec session on House
Bill
680 next we'll open an exec session on
537 relative to electric rates approved
by the Public Utilities Commission for
residential condominium property
next I make the motion of itl and
recognize Vice chair Thomas I'm sorry Mr
chairman are we doing 537 or 539 537 is
the one with the amendment that we
discussed this morning correct we are
next chair recognizes Vice chair Thomas
for a second second moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl on House
Bill
537 this is not needed because it will
be fixed by House Bill
539 no Mr chairman it's it's the other
way
around the amendment was on 537 oh it
was yeah oh I
Tom okay so I'm gonna withdraw my motion
on House Bill
to recess
the executive session on
537 until we finish House Bill
539 and now I'll open an executive
session on House Bill
and recognize Vice chair Thomas for a
motion uh 539 a motion uh itl recognize
representative
Matson I second it moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl for
House Bill 5
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the role in the question of itl for
House Bill
539 M Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative bney yes representative
Bernardi yes representative P yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall yes
representative Sebert yes representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas yes representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
representative La Rochelle yes
representative fos yes chairman Vose yes
18 Zer so by a vote of 18 to zero the
committee adopts the motion of itl on
House Bill
539 without a objection we'll put this
on
consent hearing no objection so ordered
and representative Vice chair Thomas
will write the committee
report so that closes the executive
session on
539 now we will resume the executive
537 and after discussion at
caucus we have decided that I am going
to to make a motion of itl on House Bill
537 and recognize Vice chair
Thomas second moved in seconded that we
adopt the motion of itl on House Bill
537 we decided that the amendment good
as it was doesn't really fix the
problem
and it appears after much
discussion that the best way to solve
this problem is not through legislative
action so that's why we're making the
motion of itl on this bill
representative Carman I'm sure you have
uh a different point of
view you are correct in that respect Mr
chairman uh so what course of action
would you suggest given that the
utilities at least Unitil has proven
unwilling to do what needs to be done
and given that we are in this situ
situation where people who are using
these meters for 100% residential use in
residential units are being charged
commercial
rates so we suggest this be handled
through homeowners
association um rules Andor
um
Charters um articles of agreement
whatever um we think that's the best way
to handle this and and the difference
between the amount that the people who
are being charged commercial rates and
the and residential rates is probably so
small and affects so few people that we
think that's a better way to handle this
than to put something into
legislation actually the difference
between commercial and residential rates
the rates might not be that different
but the customer charge is significantly
different um and in terms of handling it
in the way that you suggest what that
would mean would be that individuals
would be on the hook for bills that go
to other units and it's one thing for a
homeowners association to be billing
individual units that has the force of
the homeowners association but if let's
say you and I share a meter and you're
the uh account holder of record and I
decide I'm not going to pay you this
month it's going to be a problem between
us and very difficult resolve so I I
really think that the way that the
amendment spells it out is really the
best way to go to make sure that things
really work
out okay further discussion
representative Harrington yeah I would
just say uh to that is that right now
the uh the bill goes to the homeowners
association and gets built at a
commercial rate then the homeowners
association has to collect that money
from the individual homeowners that
would be the same thing as this they
would see you if you kept it going to
somebody of some centralized place
they're still forced to collect it
whether it's Bill for electricity or the
homeowners association dues the same
problem exists with people not paying
this this that's not a justification for
this because that problem already
exists further discussion representative
McGee thank you Mr chair but doesn't the
bill
simply resolve the issue of uh or force
the issue of converting this to
residential rates versus commercial
rates right it it's actually addressing
the one thing that the homeowners
association hasn't been able to resolve
with the utilities simply because they
treat homeowners associations as
commercial entities rather than um
understanding that it's not a commercial
Enterprise it's a it's a
residential uh use so that's the thing
that this simple bill was trying to
resolve and I don't I don't see how we
you go back to square one for one thing
but also so I believe that when Urus
first started testifying when Mr robar
was on the stand he said we had a bill
last year uh I don't I think it might
have been in Commerce or it was
somewhere else and um and they decided
that it could be solved outside of
legislative action but they didn't they
didn't resolve it that's why this bill
came up this year so I feel like we're
kicking the can down the road by uh
creating itl and if we pass this through
committee it gets to be discussed
through the remainder of the process and
actually have a chance at possibly being
resolved rather than us uh not solving
it for another year for folks who I
think deserve some kind of
response further discussion
representative Corman thank you one
thing that I would add is when the
subcommittee met last week there was an
attorney who was here who specializes in
condominium law and explain to us why
this solution that that's being proposed
just isn't going to work in practice and
in
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the question call the role
537 M sh Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative scheller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Sebert no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle no representative Foss no
chairman Vose yes 108 by a vote of 10
to8 the committee adopts the motion of
itl on House Bill
537 I will write the majority report
will there be a Minority Report yes
representative Corman and representative
Report okay that takes care of 537 we
close that executive session
and now we move on to House Bill 266 I
open an exact session on that bill and
recognize representative Harington for a
bill chair recognizes representative
Berney I second that moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of retain on
House Bill 266 chair recognizes
representative
Harrington yeah there seems to be a
rather strong disagreement between the
Public Utilities Commission and the
department of energy on exactly who does
what when and where we've had a lot of
going back and forth on this and
nothing's come to a conclusion so I
think this needs more work and um we
don't want to dismiss it but we don't
want to pass it either so and
retain further discussion further
discussion sorry representative
McGee I shudder to take the microphone
on this one but uh I actually thought
the changes in the bill as we uh
reviewed them when they were reverted
back to some of the original language
was quite simple and straightforward so
I didn't see it as a problem for us to I
mean I think the Pu was suggesting that
we create a study committee um it's
really just delineating who does what
and clarifying the role of the
Department of energy in the context of
pu proceedings and I didn't see anything
particularly
uh worthy of of retaining um or studying
uh but I I mean maybe we could someone
could explain to me what it is that's in
the bill that seems to be confusing
because I I didn't see anything that
straightforward well the problem seems
to be that we still don't have any kind
of agreement between the doe and the Pu
so even though the language seems pretty
straightforward to
us if they can't agree to it then it
seems further work is necessary in order
to come up with a proposal that they can
discussion representative McGee since I
brought it up I guess the way I would
view that though is um the bill I I
believe was brought by the department of
energy for clarification of what they
believe their role is and there is an
exception from the Pu that says that the
Pu doesn't see the department of
Energy's role the same so the question
would be whether our committee which
deals with both bodies and understands
both of their statutory
mandates uh can clarify that for the
world and um you know I didn't see
anything unreasonable in terms of what
the doe was proposing I think the only
issue that we have here is um how the
Public Utilities Commission sees their
role and that um they would like to have
more jurisdiction over the doe when I I
look at it that the doe has jurisdiction
over the Pu if anything they're the
overarching
agency Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chairman uh well because of that and
because there seems to be no hardcore
agreement between two departments far be
from us to get into the middle of an
argument between two departments we'd
rather have them work out something I
would rather not tell one or the other
what to do over the other it seemed like
we had a solution but then when we to
work session uh pu seemed to be a little
bit uh not quite decided and would
rather have a study well that tells me
that they really didn't accept the
solution that was offered I think more
time is needed uh for them to work it
out so that's why I would favor
retaining the
bill representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman yeah I guess
uh I guess I just Just Disagree
respectfully with with the vice chair uh
what he just said I feel like
the question here is who's the boss um
and who's the decider you know who works
for who
um it seems to me that we should decide
and uh
and pass the bill as aend as uh as we
have it before us with an amendment I
mean they did I looks to me like doe did
agree to a change that the Pu requested
but at some
point somebody needs to make a decision
I think it's us and then the agencies go
and work do their work in the way as
legislature disputes such as the one
between the doe and the Pu are usually
handled by the executive departments and
administration committee this bill was
originally assigned to that committee
but it was vacated to our committee for
a different purpose purp and that
purpose was to attach an amendment about
um something somewhat different than the
original
bill after the bill was assigned to our
committee it was determined that the
amendment that
uh was envisioned for that bill was not
Germaine and so it couldn't be done but
at that point it was too late to assign
the Bill back to vacate the bill back to
the Edna
committee I would like to defer to that
committee's expertise and how to resolve
these
complaints from you know between two
agencies before we make a decision
especially since we don't have an
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
266 V Thomas yes representative not yes
representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Sebert no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
representative fos no chairman V yes 108
so by a vote of 10 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of retain retain means
that the bill stays with the committee
it does not go to the house floor so it
will need no majority or Minority Report
representative Berney yeah just a
question so on on the bill it says
or no that's who the bill was originally
assigned to and after it got vacated to
our
committee I don't think OS at that point
changes the committee that it was
originally assigned to I think the OS
assumes that that's a house rules matter
not a OS drafting matter so that's why
the original committee stays listed on
the bill I hope that answers your
question yeah thank you you
bet all right so we'll close that uh
executive session and now we'll open an
executive session on House Bill 759 FN
chair recognizes representative
Harrington
down this one I move to itl
inappropriate to legislate chair
recognizes representative N I second the
motion moved and seconded that we itl
Harrington to tell you the truth I
didn't think I was speaking on this bill
but so maybe somebody else can pick it
up because I I didn't realize I was
being tked with this I'd have to look up
my
notes Okay so so this bill is the
customer generator bill that expands uh
the definition
of customer generator to include
something called Community generator and
there were enough problems with this
bill that we just didn't think it was
ready for prime time and need needed
further work before we could go forward
with it and um that's basically our
rationale further discussion
representative
Corman so given that you just said that
the bill needs further work could we
bill we could but we want to try to
minimize retains to the bills that were
that were absolutely baffled
over well I mean we seem kind of baffled
over this one or at least some some of
us
do well that's not why how we feel on
our side further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll in the question
759 V Shar Thomas yes representative ner
yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative MC
no Representative parall no
representative
Sebert no representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas no representative Corman no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle no representative F no chairman
oose yes
108 okay by a vote of 10 to8 we adopt
the motion of itl on House Bill
759 representative Harrington will write
the committee majority report will there
be a Minority Report yes that'll be uh
Corman
okay we'll close the executive session
on House Bill
759 and now move to an executive session
for House Bill
760 and I will make the motion of itl
and recognize Vice chair Thomas there a
second
moved and seconded that we adopt the
motion of itl on House Bill
760 the rationale here is that there is
an open docket at the Pu that needs to
comp We Believe needs to complete before
any action could be taken on this uh on
this bill
this entire
situation focuses on how to eliminate
some middleman costs
and if that can be done in a with
minimal risk it could save some very
serious money for rate payers in the
long
term so we feel that uh we don't need to
do take any action on this at this time
we talked about possibly retaining this
bill but we feel we don't really need to
do that uh if it becomes a problem in
the long term that we'll deal with it at
that time further disc
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman so which docket are we
saying that we are we're uh pushing this
off for because we're waiting for some
kind of
decision you want the docket number well
I guess the reason I'm asking is because
of the order that came out Friday that
basically uh closed or dissolved the
pending docket that I believe would
22-06 and that was the one that was on
um uh distributed utility net metering
tariffs and the uh compensation
basically for de the looking at all of
those issues that we've been trying to
get a handle on for a while that docket
we just got an order on Friday saying
it's gone to an investigative State and
maybe never to be heard from again
there's there's no more uh imperative to
get that one out the door so if we're
saying we're going to defer to something
that should be coming out of the Public
Utilities Commission then maybe we
should
be uh sure that it's actually still
going at the
Pu because there may not be any answer
coming anytime
soon good question the docket that was
closed on Friday is a net metering
docket doesn't relate to this issue the
three dockets that do relate to this
issue are the e24 d122
de
064 and those dockets uh are all
concerning um the utilities use of a
non- bypassable charge to rec recover
costs related to the use of um the spot
Market when buying
load for their respective
utilities f discussion needed
representative McGee yeah the the docket
was not just net metering tariffs though
it also related to compensation
for distributed energy resources I
believe it the docket had kind of a long
title and it it it wasn't just on the
net metering
tariff I have to go find it Well I read
it on Friday afternoon or actually on
Saturday I believe and
um the way I understood it it was about
the net metering docket that had been
opened back in
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of the adoption of the motion of itl for
a house
760 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
n yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative
Sebert no representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas no representative Corman no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle no representative fos no
chairman oose
yes M
108 by the vote of 10 to8 we adopt the
motion of itl on House Bill 760 I will
write the majority opinion will there be
a Minority Report yes representative
Corman representative
Corman it's getting all
okay with that we'll close the exec
session on House Bill
760 next we'll move to House Bill 761 I
open an exec session and recognize
representative
PL thank you I motion to itl HB
761 chair recognizes representative
Bernardi I second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of itl
761 I believe the big issue here is the
issue of how to
prevent charging a battery from the grid
and then selling the energy back at a
higher cost at some later time there are
no guard rails in the bill
whatsoever the the basic premise of the
bill makes sense but without guard rails
we just decided we couldn't move forward
discussion representative Corman thank
you I I don't recall that coming up
during the discussion of the bill uh
maybe did but I don't recall call it um
but the main thing is that the bill
allows for the Department to adopt rules
in the commission to approve tariffs and
issue orders so in fact that situation
that you just described can be handled
in that
way sort of except that the adoption of
rules has to have a legislative
imperative so just saying that the
commission or the department
should adopt rules doesn't give them any
direction about what those rules should
look
like that's where the guardrails aspect
comes into play if we'd have told them
okay we need you to adopt rules
to
prevent uh the charging of the battery
from
non from the grid and then the selling
back of the electricity at a later date
at a high rate or higher cost then that
would have given them something to go on
but without spelling it out in
legislation they have no no basis on
which to make a rule given that could we
retain the bill and make that addition
to the bill and
year if we're going to wait and pass it
next year maybe a a better bill that
spells everything out would be the
better way to
go representative L
roell yes it's to me this sounds like a
free market incentive to do load
leveling and therefore provides a
system thank you further comment Vice
chair Thomas thank you Mr chair yeah I I
have to agree with uh the chairman here
I absolutely liked the this bill I
thought it made a lot of sense but it
was lacking a key ingredient to have a
guard rail it's not our it's not our
place to fix bills like that if there
was a window perhaps but uh I think like
they say here uh you you can resubmit
next year on this although the whole
idea of the bill I liked but we need to
have some concrete guard rail so that
rules representative McGee thank you Mr
chair and I just want to piggyback on
representative lar shelle's point
because what I was going to say is that
um if we do have a free market then what
we want is we want accurate price
signals and if someone does have a
battery even if if the sheller plant the
plants that are going to solar and
batteries if they decide that they want
to uh make sure their batteries are full
at a time when prices are lower and then
put energy onto the system when the
prices are higher that's not them that's
not them rigging anything that's them
being paid the value for providing
energy that again shaves the load when
we want the load shaved so there's a
there's an increased value and um energy
isn't the same cost at all times of day
and I and so and it's that way for a
reason right so I I think because the
value has already been established that
when we need the energy and everybody's
trying to get energy that's when we want
more energy on the system that there
there needs to be sort of a premium paid
to those people who are able to put
energy on the system at that time that's
the market working the way it's supposed
to that's what the bill is supposed to
do is to uh enable storage which is
something that again we've been kind of
holding back for um you know a lack of
our understanding to be able to enable
it but this bill doesn't do anything
that would be
uh detrimental to the market it it
actually leverages the market which I
think was the point that representative
L Rell was trying to make and quite
quite good for your first major
contribution thanks representative
reels thank you Mr chairman yeah just
following on to what my um ranking
member just said
uh I believe that both the Department of
energy and the Public Utilities
Commission uh operate under statutory
requirement to
do set rates and and make policy and
such that you know rates are just and
reasonable so why don't we just Empower
them you know charge them with doing
their job doing the thing that this bill
uh would Empower them to do and trust
that they'll do it I don't think that
the committee needs I'm I'm trying to
wrap my head around what we would even
put into the bill that we would then
specify I mean that's why we have
executive agencies with expertise to do
the things that we policy makers say do
you know and um enable storage to
contribute value to the Grid in a way
that's fair and trust that they'll do
discussion representative McGee I guess
the last question is you know in seeing
bills go down that are at least um
looking to assist the competitive market
and and assist the local sustainable
generation and storage aspects of the
New Hampshire energy Market I just want
to ask what benefit we think we gain by
delaying that another year um storage
should not be
controversial and having a concern about
somebody
making some kind of ill-gotten gain
because they discharge their energy when
it's uh more valuable I mean most people
that invest in storage which is quite
expensive would be looking to do that
that's something we want so we don't
really need to police that at this at at
this level um because the storage adds
the benefit uh of Greater stability to
the
system and also again shaving load so
those are both desirable aspects that
get enabled by this bill and we don't we
don't have to make all the decisions
about how the rules will work out or how
the Public Utilities Commission will
extend valuation but we I I don't see
why we would kill a bill that all of us
initially thought was a good
bill um when we don't have a good reason
to kill the bill and to delay further
when people are really seeking for us to
solve this stuff
further discussion representative Corman
thank you you know I we we talk a lot
about reliability as well and storage is
an important aspect of that you know you
think about what uh what was going on
New Year's Eve of 22 when several
generators were were down storage could
have been a big part of that solution
and you know we need to be doing what we
can for storage it is time shifted
generation shifted to when it's needed
further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role in the question
761 right sh sure Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes represent Bry yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes repres
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Sebert no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
representative fos no chairman Vose yes
108 by a vote of 10 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of itl on House Bill
761 representative clog will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report in the tradition of the day it
will be representative
Corman I I would have imagined that it
okay with that we'll close the executive
session on House Bill
761 and while I failed to mention it
before I will mention it now that all
the committee reports need to be
Tuesday all right now we've got two
bills to go so we'll open an exec
session on House Bill
692 chair recognizes representative
n thank you Mr chairman I move itl chair
recognizes representative Matson I
second moved and seconded that we itl
House Bill 69
2 and the chair recognizes
representative
nter thank you Mr chairman just a bottom
line is this um bill is very expensive
project between 320 to $430
million and util the utilities already
do long range planning and to integrate
distribution
plans so we had an extensive discussion
on this this
morning centered around a
amendment that representative McGee
offered
which at first blush looked like a
useful Amendment but after we talked
about it for quite some time it became
apparent that that amendment was uh not
something that was going to
work uh or that would would result in
a useful report that the committee could
make some use of going
forward so I think that's the uh the
explanation for why at itl is the
best the best way forward for this bill
further discussion representative McGee
thank you well um I had suggested before
we left our work session that perhaps a
study committee would be the way to go
so that we could actually get our act
together as a committee in terms of what
we would like to understand because the
issue of five years before anything
begins on upgrades to
technology um I I I don't know if that's
adequate or if that's holding up the
competitive markets or if that's um
detrimental to
um to customers I mean I I think it's
something that is really worthy of a
study which is why I propose that and I
realize that itl is now the motion on
the floor but um but I would ask that
folks vote against the itl cuz just just
killing the work doesn't make it go away
I mean uh this is stuff we still need
answers to so this may not be the right
solution and I will admit that I I think
the chairman knows I sort of rushed to
Market with an amendment to take out the
uh pieces that were suggesting how
eversource could move forward with uh
converting uh interim meters you know
adop meters in the time period between
now and the 5 years when they plan to
redo them all um I was trying to make
sure that we were saving people money
there was never any uh cost evaluation
on this bill that said it was hundreds
of thousands of dollars I wasn't asking
them to replace all the meters so we
just have to read the bill but the what
I was offering with the
amendment was the idea that we should uh
have some better sense of when when
certain capabilities are going to be
supported and right now we don't have
that answer and we're saying it's going
to be answered over at the Public
Utilities Commission but it we don't
have any timelines for any turnaround on
this so is it 6 months is it one year is
it 18 months will we'd be doing this in
two years why can't we solicit our own
information so we have an idea what can
and cannot be enabled and I I just I
discussion representative
Harrington whether you look at the amend
the am the newest Amendment or the bill
itself the me of the bill is that they
going to get a report on compliance with
FK order
2222 so be submitted no late in November
1st
2025 and my concern the issue there is
that that's going to be a public
document they subit to FK anyone that
wants a copy of it you would have get
one we don't need a law to to obtain a
copy of a filing the utility makes with
FKS deadline may be November 1st of
2026 further discussion representative
Corman thank you one issue that always
comes up in bills like this is the uh
software changes that need to be made in
the back end of the systems at Utilities
in particular ever source and um I'm
hoping Mr Lata is paying attention as
I'm saying this but it seems that either
these systems are Baroque and perhaps
written in coall so that it's very hard
to find programmers who can work on them
or the programmers are way overpaid
given the amount of money that we hear
that these changes are going to require
I I just find it hard to believe that
some of these changes are going to
require some of the amounts of money
that we've been hearing and I'm not
speaking specifically about this bill
but we just keep hearing it over and
over you know it sounds like changing
one line of code is going to cost
$100,000 um I know enough about software
having been in computer science for 51
years that it's not that it's not as
expensive as we're hearing and it seems
to me that a lot of what we're hearing
is an excuse for
inertia further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl for House Bill
692 Vier Thomas yes representative n yes
representative Harrington yes
representative brne yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative
Sebert no representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas no representative Corman no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle no representative fos no
108 by V of 10 to8 the committee adopts
the motion of itl on HB
692 representative n will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report yes there will and that that
would representative Corman that would
be me oh representative McGee okay which
one is this is 692 right yeah yeah
692 so representative n will write the
majority representative McGee will write
the minority the report okay close the
exact session on 692 leaves us with one
bill to
go I'll open an exec session on House
bernardy I make a motion to itl
755 chair recognizes representative
schneller second moved and seconded that
we adopt the motion of itl on House Bill
750 5 chair recognizes repr
representative
Bernardi so we have many issues in this
bill that are under cons consideration
by both the doe and pu this is a
recurring pattern of trying to push a
bill before we have uh our
administrative agency's work complete uh
it further codifies some things that uh
we we were codifying them in the law
before we even know what they are
we had all regulatory all regulated
utilities come up and oppose this bill
um we have load settlement charges that
benefit only one
organization uh and uh we had uh
testimony that time of use rates that
were uh available by the uh Cooperative
were really not uh well accepted at time
so this is this is a bill before its
time
further discussion representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman well that's
the perfect example for what I had asked
for again a study um there may be
aspects of this bill that could not go
forward or could not be defined in
statute at this time under the arguments
that were made but there are other
aspects where again we are playing
chicken and egg with the Public
Utilities Commission saying that they
are going going to come up with a
decision and then when they don't come
up with a decision we we we keep
defaulting to them and when when
actually it's it's our job to figure out
if there are laws that we should be
defining that will help guide them they
don't seem to be able to sort these
issues out any better or faster than we
are sorting them they they're they're
punting on things that have been with
them for three years and or more so uh
our
ability to rely on the Public Utilities
Commission to resolve these issues and
also to be impartial in terms of
viewing all the parties that are
involved it's it we're in a time of
change they're going to have to figure
out they're going to have to figure out
how to accommodate a competitive market
which we haven't had for very long so
somebody has to cry Uncle here and um I
think getting rid of all these bills
including this one which is about
completing
reforms um that the energy Market is in
need of this one more than any of them
would make a great study committee but
if we're going to itl all of them then
we're basically deferring all of the
hard work that's been put in front of us
this year um to advance again the
competitive market and that's that's the
only way I can describe it we're the
ones that said we wanted competition and
now we're um we're allowing another
entire year to go by without responding
and saying well it's going to happen
over there but it it hasn't been
happening I mean there have been no no
answers on any of the questions we're
not putting storage into the statutory
language to give guidance this year so
is the Pu going to want to move forward
they're going to say oh it's not in the
statutory language and the same thing's
going to be happening for the reforms
that are listed in in 755
so I I am in favor of this committee
actually digging in and trying to figure
out what we can accomplish this year
rather than just moving all of the you
know the difficult work off uh as though
responsibility further discussion
representative Corman thank you you know
at some
point we have to say damn it we're the
legislature we're the ones who make the
the the laws we're the ones who tell the
executive agencies what they are
supposed to do and if they're not
getting it done then we have to light a
fire under them and they're not getting
it done we need to be lighting fires
under these executive agencies that
aren't getting things done all the
authority all the power that the
executive agencies have derive from the
legislature and I think sometimes we
just have to throw our weight around and
do further
discussion representative Sebert I would
just like to make a comment that um you
know there's a lot of folks specifically
in this room that like to say constantly
bash Congress for how they can't get
anything done and how they don't do
their job and right now we've become
just that that's what that's what's
happening right here and I would just um
even go further and say that it's it's
not a we are doing that um it's one side
of the aisle in this room thank you
thank you for your comments
representative I'm going to have to
disagree with all three of you on this
point you cannot mandate
competition competition occurs because
people want
it and if there is a human cry from the
general public about having a utility
Market that's different from the one we
have today then the public will rise up
and inform the utilities that they want
changes made and the utilities being
customer oriented will make sure that
that change
happens but we as a legislature cannot
mandate those
changes without running the risk of
seriously damaging the existing
structure competition and Innovation
does not come from the top down it comes
from the bottom up and you can't mandate
Innovation representative Corman thank
you you can't vote for your utility you
can vote for your representative but you
can't vote for your utility I can't vote
oh I'm going to leave Liberty and go to
eversource
I can vote for a different rep but I
can't vote to do that so I disagree with
that
premise you can talk to your utility
though and tell them what you want and
if enough people do that the utility
will do that I think that's one of the
reasons the community power Coalition
exists is because they determined that
they could have a bigger Collective
voice
by gathering a bunch of people together
to try to make change and they are
working in the direction of doing that
and as they gain experience maybe
they'll get good at it in the future the
utility is what we call a natural
monopoly so I mean I I can't I can't
switch utilities I can switch electric
suppliers but that's all I can
switch I understand that point but you
still can't mandate innovation res uh
representative
reinolds thank you Mr chairman um you
know it's hard to disagree perhaps with
a lot of what you said you know in the
kind of in the abstract
but energy markets the particularly
electricity Market what we deal with
most of the time it's not a free market
it's a highly regulated market the there
players individual customers have
limited
choices they also have limited knowledge
it's really complicated stuff how does
the electricity that powers my home get
here and what are all the inputs and
what are all the costs involved
transmission distribution the other
charges it's all very complicated it's
our job here at the science technology
and energy committee to represent the
people they're not going to call the
utility and say I want to do this so
that's what we're doing we're not I
don't think think the bills that we have
been talking about today are mandating
enabling the evolution of the
competitive market for electricity that
was set in motion back in
1997 nearly 30 years ago when when the
state of New Hampshire you know
deregulated the utilities made the
Monopoly utilities divest of generation
and ushered in the rest it's been almost
30 years and we're still waiting for the
truly competitive market for many of
these Energy Services to
evolve and it's our job to continue to
make small changes small policy
changes and then charge our department
of energy and pu with putting those
changes into place this committee and
the Full House just adopted your bill Mr
chairman a couple of weeks ago stating a
new energy policy for the State of New
Hampshire and it had a lot in it about
competition and Market forces but that
stuff's not going to come forward all by
itself and it isn't going to come
forward by allowing the utilities to
keep saying
well we don't know enough yet to do that
and we've got a plan that starts 5 years
from now to put that enabling technology
in place and and then the Pu with this
docket that they started three years ago
only to come out last Friday and say
oh it's closed no
conclusion I mean really three years of
delay waiting for policy to come out and
then nothing and I don't think we should
that so I hear what you're
saying but I have to respectfully
disagree in 1997 we structured the re
restructured the electricity Market to
try to encourage
competition if we had been successful
there would be no such thing as default
service right
now everybody would be getting their
electricity from an alternative
supplier but that hasn't
happened because there's no motivation
on the part of the average
person to go out and do the hard work of
chasing down an alternative supplier
from whom they can buy cheaper
electricity they're
there and people could be buying from
them if they really wanted to but
apparently they don't so a lot of people
still re rely on default service that's
why it
exists
and I don't think there are barriers to
that
competition it's there people can take
advantage of it if they want to so far
they don't want to because they're
basically satisfied with the St status
quo
and while I do agree that there are
things we can do to remove barriers and
improve the status quo I don't
necessarily think the bill that we're
considering right now is one of
those representative
chair Innovation you can't mandate it
but you can provide an environment that
encourages it it I'm a retired research
scientist and I work for Dupont and as
you may know Dupont was a very
Innovative company because they provided
an environment that encouraged
Innovation uh personally I
received significant financial awards
for Innovations I
made uh I was allowed time to do
research in areas that wasn't part of my
assignment resulting again in
Innovations I think you have to provide
encourage ment and room for Innovation
to
occur thank
you a point well taken and I would
remind everyone that deont is a private
company they're not the government and
mandates from the government take a
different form than encouragement from a
private
company representative Berne has a
comment thank you chairman just just to
add to that um in the private company
case
um they have an incentive a financial
profit incentive to take risks and and
make a profit from that in this case the
utility uh most of their uh Capital
Investments or any other cost they just
they they I mean they have an incentive
to do a reasonable job but they don't
have an incentive to
um they they don't profit from from
their choices in that sense so um and
maybe if if the bill allowed them to
profit I don't know um that's something
to think about I
guess representative Corman thank you um
regarding your comments Mr chairman
about people being satisfied with
default service first of all a huge
percentage of our state is not on
default service and is being served by
the community power Coalition including
your town and my
town but there are other situations for
example when I first heard about
competitive Supply Long before Community
power I actually checked it out and what
I saw was that I'd be getting locked
into a contract and I didn't want to
locked into a contract with default
service all right there's no contract
and I can maybe go to community power or
not now I have to be on default service
choice further discussion representative
McGee thank you Mr chair yeah the point
that I wanted to make is back to the
environment that we are providing in the
state it it isn't a mandate to recognize
the fact that if you don't have a Level
Playing Field then competition is skewed
right in a competitive market you want
to just start everybody on a Level
Playing Field and so what what we've
learned since enabling Community power
to come into being is that it's like
having a public option right that there
owned by their members they're uh
transparent in that you can attend their
meetings you can see all their minutes
online and they're working directly with
towns with representatives in those
towns who can communicate back to the
governments of those Towns how they
operate what they're what you know what
changes are undergoing in the company so
it's a a service or oriented
organization with a mission of bringing
lower costs and what they're finding
since we enabled them to become that
competitive uh player in the market here
in New Hampshire is that there are
aspects of their business that they
can't deliver on because the um the I
don't want to say Monopoly utilities but
basically the default utilities you know
have the advantage they're they have the
home field advantage right they own the
poles and wires they own the
interconnections they uh they own the
data they own the you name it a villing
and so and so
as we have enabled somebody to become a
major player in the state we've also
failed to continue to look at the other
issues around the business model and
that isn't about mandating anything it's
about recognizing whether it's a Level
Playing Field whether there's anything
else we should be doing in order to
fully realize the value of the
competition that we you know we started
it but then maybe we didn't know how to
bring it into full being and so the
stuff that's being put in front of us a
lot of it is being penned by you know
Cliff below because he is so
knowledgeable in in energy and we can
say well we we like that or we don't
like that or we want to help them or we
don't want to help them it isn't really
about all of that it's about they are
already an established player they are
already representing towns all over New
Hampshire so we should be looking at the
issues they're bringing to us to see
whether there's any thing we need to do
and instead we're going to it itl all
these bills and just disregard it all
and I I don't understand inexpedient to
legislate on these bills if we don't
understand what reforming uh the market
should look like we should study it we
road one of the things you forgot to
mention in your thoughtful remarks that
you just made was that
the incumbent utilities own something
else that's incredibly important they
own the reliability of our electric
grid and that is probably more important
than anything else the reliability of
the grid we always want it to be there
people get very upset when they lose
their electricity yeah they'd also like
it to be cheap who wouldn't
but the main thing they care about is
reliability and anything that tampers
with the existing market for electricity
runs the risk of decreasing the
reliability of the grid so we have to be
very careful and very deliberate when we
make
decisions that will make
changes that could jeopardize the
reliability of our grid that's one of
the things that I have emphas I ized
repeatedly over the last couple of years
is that
reliability is job number one for this
legislature as far as the electric grid
is
concerned representative
Sebert um instead of well I guess
because a lot of terms are being used
here but I would just say like consumer
protections should be one of our number
one goals here um and fighting for the
consumer and I think assuming that
they're just complacent is completely
wrong um to do thank you thank you for
reinforcing my point the consumer wants
reliability and that's what we're
fighting for representative
Foss but if their grid is not reliable
then we are removing their ease of them
finding another option not everyone is
satisfied with the existing reliability
of their default service it it
definitely depends on where you are in
the state so we are removing the their
reliable okay representative McGee yeah
um I think everyone agrees with the
reliability I mean we have words that
represent Concepts that we all agree on
of course we want reliable energy but
that's not what we're discussing um
whoever is supplying our energy we
expect it to be reliable and of course
the people who
are uh maintaining the poles and wires
and the systems that help us when
there's a storm and there's outages yeah
there's Great Value in in what the
utilities do I'm not I'm not questioning
that I'm saying we have a new player in
the market we have uh we have the
ability to hold back their ability to
fully participate or um the ability to
figure out what the new paradigm is so
everybody can play together in the pool
the right way and it means more work
with with the utilities and with the any
other competitors competitive suppliers
to figure out what that balance is but
the Pu isn't getting it done the Pu
isn't answering the important questions
about the value of net metering and
changes to the Tariff when they get
stakeholders coming in front of them
saying this is what we think it should
be they say well we have different
information which we can't show you but
we've developed our own evidence so
that's that's new you know it it that's
not the way the Pu has traditionally
operated and so the legislature can't
stand silent in the face of no decisions
when it's affecting businesses and it's
affecting rate payers out there who are
expecting uh the markets to operate to
their benefit and uh the players are
doing their best to try and they're
doing their best to try and provide
those services but right now you know I
I don't want to say the legislator the
Pu I don't want to just even point
fingers but just saying the government
of the State of New Hampshire is is not
helping we're in the way because we're
not bothering to address the very real
concerns that are being brought to
us all right we start to seem to be
going around in circles here
representative
Harrington yeah rather than talk about
General philosophy I'd like to talk
about the bill just a little bit um and
on page three of the bill it talks about
pursuant to relevant ISO New England
tariffs and so forth it sounds as if
we're getting in the the states getting
in the regulation of iso wholesale
markets and we're dealing with the uh
some report that's not going to be out
until November 1st 2026 I think we
should see the report before we start
putting that the results of that report
okay I think we've gone on long enough
about this debate so I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role on the
question of the motion of itl on House
Bill
755 blacker Thomas yes representative
nder yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Khan yes representative
Matson yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Sebert no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no no
Representative rolds no representative
La relle no representative Foss no
chairman Bose yes 108 by a vote of 10
to8 the committee adopts the motion of
itl on House Bill 755 representative
bernardy will write the majority report
will there be a Minority Report There
Will and that will be representative
Wendy
Thomas okay with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
755 and that concludes our activity for
the
day thank you everyone for your hard
work and your thoughtful discussion of
these important
issues and
with luck that will take care of our
activity for the month of March we
probably will not return to these
hallowed Halls until April when we take
up some Senate bills does anybody have
any business to bring before the
committee before we
adjourn
comment Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair it might be an opportunity to look
at perhaps um a field trip or two or
present
so with our the time that we have
through the rest of this month so I'll
ask representative Matson to get on the
stick and see what we can put together
everyone anything
else seeing nothing I want to thank you
all again for being here today and we'll